the following is a presentation of the
saint louis chess club
old legends are defined in new ones
forged at the u.s juniors and senior
championships in saint louis former u.s
women's champion jennifer yu hasn't
given up on another title taking down
the undefeated leader sophie mora suzuki
to join a three-way tie for second
christopher yu fell to tailender david
brodsky but holds a tenuous half point
lead in the juniors feeling the pressure
in the seniors larry christensen turned
up the heat winning his game to regain
sole lead
leaders have proven to be mortal who
will rise up to challenge them
round eight of incredible chess coming
up next
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back everybody to day eight of
the us juniors and seniors chess
championships held here at the st louis
chess club we start the day in front of
the iconic st louis chess club where all
the magic happens well it's a hot day
here in st louis and the games are
heating up as well let's go to the
studio and start this exciting round
hello everyone and welcome to the
beautiful city of saint louis host to
three national championships the girls
the juniors the seniors we are in the
penultimate round and we are at the st
louis chess club here in saint louis
hello everyone i'm your host yasir
sarawan along with doors
i am so
revved up by the fact that we've had so
many
brilliant decisive games yesterday that
i'm just still a little bit on edge
hello everyone uh
can you believe it
13
13 out of the 15 decisive games played
yesterday were decisive 86.7
are you kidding me this is unheard of if
it said 86.7 percent draws i'd say yeah
we're at the sinkhole cup that's what
happens
i i'm flabbergasted
and it's classical chess by the way too
do the honors where are standings after
let's start with the girls yes let's do
it yes
so sophomore suzuki lost her game
unfortunately yesterday she couldn't
really make a fabiano heaven
but she still has six out of seven and
she is being followed by jennifer you
italian cervantes and roshogu they're
these three ladies are tied for second
and they all have five points very nice
and in the juniors christopher you also
lost his uh game yesterday not a good
day for our leaders it really wasn't
right uh he still has a little bit of a
lead though he has five out of five and
a half out of seven but he he does have
a very close um
chase is a rival yeah andrew hung at
one and a half points behind but a big
round coming up and and then the seniors
it's a little closer when yesterday it
was a three-way tie yes well not anymore
so the larry christensen managed to win
a very beautiful game and he is on seoul
leader with five points but he is being
followed by vladimir kopian four and a
half points and now we actually
yeah we see him sitting there getting
ready oh i can't see the openings he's
thinking about it
what am i going to do what am i going to
do
larry
enjoying a half a point lead and as we
get a look at the tournament playing
hall
uh again uh penultimate round but the
format let's go for it yeah
uh well it's quite a classic uh event
right so ten players nine rounds it's a
round robin uh the time the time for
each player you get 90 minutes
for the first 40 moves then when you
complete your 40th move you get 30
minutes for the rest of the game and to
top it off you do get 30 second
increments from the first move right and
there are no draw offers before a third
fifth move but i mean i don't think
that's been that's been an issue here
and the classic um classic point system
you win you get one point you draw you
get half you lose you get as fixed
between you get nothing but what would
happen if there was a playoff amongst
two people oh boy well if two players
are tied you get two rapid matches okay
if you still end up tied then you're
gonna go armageddon and that's the end
of it and what if there's a three or
even a four-way player type for first
i'm glad we've thought of this true
we get rapid round robins
if you all are still tied we'll get a
blitz match which could also be a round
open we'll have to see how many people
and if you're still tied then finally
armageddon exactly now here
so sophia our leader in the ladies she
kind of let her grasp on the trophy slip
yesterday she still got a one-point lead
so she has every reason to be confident
but
sometimes you get rattled that first
loss right and we're lucky to have
christian in studio to drill down on
these players and their road ahead it's
not easy being first christian in these
events
it's great to be back with you two guys
calling the games of the best juniors as
well as the best legends that we have on
american soil and the tournaments are
heating up this is it the championship
round so let's take a look at where we
stand in terms of standings as well as
the road ahead for our leaders and we're
going to start with the girls section we
have sophie maurice suzuki six out of
seven she was one game away of pulling a
fabiano caruana that is a seven out of
seven reminiscent of fabiano field cup
performance in 2014 but
we do have three players tied for second
position we have jennifer eu rochelle as
well as well talia cervantes who our
leader will be playing in the ninth
round but today round eight well this is
a big opportunity for her to potentially
score an important crucial victory
against anne marie vela who has been
struggling in this event as you can see
she only scored one point out of seven
so definitely a big chance for her and
take a look that is talia she knows that
she needs to win today to keep close
contact with the leader sophie mori
suzuki and give herself a chance to
potentially equalize her score maybe
even take over and take the lead and the
championship in the last round and let's
take a look at where we stand in the
junior section well this one is a very
compact standing we have christa for you
at the top five and a half out of seven
unfortunately for him he lost
yesterday a very difficult game against
david brassie he actually lost with the
white pieces that was a big surprise for
everybody andrew hong took advantage of
that one with the black pieces as well
against brandon jacobson and right now
he's only half a point behind
christopher un one abi manu mishra the
youngest grand master in history with
four points one and a half points behind
but today abimanu has a big chance to
potentially uh not catch up with the
leader but get closely behind the leader
if he manages to win against christopher
you big clash we see this one in round
number nine christopher you will be
playing against i have to say a
struggling karissa yip so today is the
big day for christopher you and let's
take a look at where we stand in our
final section that is the seniors
section we have one leader that is larry
christensen who took over the event
yesterday with a brilliant win with
black pieces but vladimir kopian is also
warming up in the tournament only half a
point behind him and then we see tied
for third position we have dimitri
gravich alex cabalov and maxime at
lugian let's take a look at the road
ahead for larry christensen i have to
say this tournament is so compact and
these two games are crucial and very
difficult one against chabalov today
well that one is going to be an
explosive affair we know both of these
players love to go for the kill and this
is exactly what we're going to see today
and in round number nine against mr
gurevich also closely behind and as you
can see the seniors are having a good
time around each other chatting with our
arbiter chief arbiter chris a bird
getting ready for the competition to
start guys we're going to have some
amazing games
absolutely thank you so much for that
christian and
set the table for us doris
and tell us about all the pairings
beginning it with the girls let's go for
it well sophie uh sophie morris suzuki
is having a
fantastic
lesson time
and she does have a very nice chance to
win today and
secure at least the playoffs absolutely
and all of those players with five
points they need to win to put pressure
on sofia and in the junior section
christopher you is playing the mishra
who wow you know he wants to win the
other he wants to win it's going to be a
big big battle between these two
very nice marquis match up andrew hung
versus a wonderling will also be a
marquee match-up for us and in the
seniors
it's going to be a fun one because as
the christian was just saying uh
christian sin
right
is playing shabal of today and guravage
tomorrow and both tribal of gurevich
are you know very close rivals coming up
absolutely so it's going to be a lot of
fun
yep and of course they've been battling
and fighting their hearts out what are
they fighting for oh if at first
there we see the start of the game
michelle
uh as she just pressed the clock i
i saw her i enjoyed her interview
yesterday i thought she was wonderful
she's a sweet party really and i once
again i just gotta throw that out there
bret brandon jacobson yesterday lost to
andrew hung but take a look at that game
that was the brilliancy of the
tournament as the round's underway there
we see our assistant arbiter going right
through the sections making sure
one of our photographers yeah i believe
that's leonard leonard otis the yeah
always colorfully
haired he can't pull it
and we owe a great deal of thanks to
leonard because he runs all the game
boards making sure that the digital
boards and the transmissions
and here we have our tournament leader
sophie
again um dorsa
you've played in these events you
understand the competitive nature of the
players you lose a first game like
sophie did yesterday
what's your
how do you bounce back you just say
it didn't happen i mean shh
if i'm not the second it is her last
year playing in this exactly so you know
she's
she already has had a beautiful event uh
something that's you know she's gonna
put on a resume people are gonna talk
about it right
um but
she still has a clear lead so i don't
think it's gonna affect her too much
and i just don't think today is the day
for her to go all risky i think in my
opinion she should try to
have some
comfortable position know her opening
don't try to go
g4g5
and kill somebody yeah i completely
disagree with you
sorry uh to say that but i think this is
the big chance that sophie has to score
an important victory and i mean there's
three players chasing her very closely
behind are you really going to bank
everything on uh none of them winning
and tomorrow you have such a difficult
clash let's not forget she's playing
white against a struggling player also a
player that is 200 rated lower uh rated
than her so there's quite a big
difference she really needs to make a
push in this one tomorrow she's playing
one of the rating favorites talia
cervantes with the black pieces so i
feel this is a must-win situation for uh
sophie
definitely not take as many risks but
play a long game and do not allow your
opponent to exchange pieces to get close
and comfortable uh close to a draw i
agree i feel like i mean this is not a
do or die situation but i agree she
should be pushing she should be making
it long she should be kind of waiting
for the lower rated player to make
mistakes
yeah well already an indication to me
with the move knights e3
that uh sophie uh
wants to play
um
a long game right i mean
and after knight e5
also an indication to me that she wants
to play a sharp game so with the move
knight e5 it opens up this bishop which
supports the advance e2 e4 so for
example if we see a very standard move
like bishop to b7 then white wants to
play e2 e4 and start this immediate
clash in the center again this is going
to be one of the the games that we watch
talia
uh rochelle
and
jennifer are all a point behind and
they're saying to uh anna marie come on
now's your time now's your chance to
pull off an upset i just see and let's
not forget jennifer is playing with the
white pieces against a struggling player
right now gracie prasanna so
a big chance of potentially scoring
another victory and getting closer and
closer to sophie if sophie makes a draw
do you really uh want to see yourself uh
three rounds to go you had a two-point
uh lead right one round to go playing
against one of the rating favorite you
only have half a point lead
i don't think you want to be in that
situation psychologically also is going
to be a very difficult situation so i
think she needs to win this game
clear uh just
taking a look at the game between
jennifer you as white versus gracie
funnily enough uh jennifer's actually
been playing a slav defense and that's
the defense that gracie chose today with
this
topical line of play knight h4 bishop g6
queen b3 queen c7 uh white usually tries
to delay this capture
uh because notice that the queen
any captures on g6 will open up an
attack against the pawn on h2 but this
was a game
this is a line i want to say pardon me
that one vessel in topolof has played
throughout his career as white he loves
the two bishops
and with the castle's long
double-edged game just what jennifer is
hoping for and again jennifer one of
those trailers by one point
um
she needs to win this is a do-or-die
game for her if she has aspirations for
first place of course i was also looking
at the tomorrow's pairing and jennifer
is playing uh anna marie who is also
struggling exactly so
jennifer's really hoping that she can
put together back-to-back victories uh
to contest
for that first prize let's go uh to the
junior
championship who do you want to start
with always our tournament leader we
have to uh we have to respect where and
where is this
there he is
and again he's whoa whoa
whoa
we just got here and then the game
blowed up uh what the heck okay this is
a london system with bishop coming to f4
uh the c5 uh we've all been here know
this knight c6
knight d2 uh queen b6 all very very well
known stuff
captures captures c4
bishop f5
and now
a move i'm sorry to say i'm unfamiliar
with i see it's in my database
i just have not studied this move
whatsoever i know nothing
now and bishop e4 this all is being
played as if it's routine help me out uh
christian i am struggling to understand
g4 at least to my database according to
the database that we have right g4 is a
novelty what it was responded uh with
bishop to e4 which is by far the best
move in the position and actually the
only move that keeps the not necessarily
keeps the balance but does not allow
white to take over the initiative bishop
to e4 the best move in the position
bishop to g2 this is the position and
guess what the best move according to
the engine is
g5 what get lost yes
g5
g5 and the second best move is e5 e5
makes much more e5 i can't understand e5
you can understand g5 not so much but i
guess the idea is
look your king is not going to go on the
queen side once you already lost the b2
pawn most likely you will focus on
getting it to the king side if you
really want to castle and i think you do
because you need to bring your rook into
place somehow so
what black is trying to do with this
move well open up the lines open up the
g file specifically after rook to g8 we
get this type of position and then i
understand black maybe will keep the
king in center the way i see it i think
black will like to keep the king in the
center maybe even go long castle
nevertheless you still have to be wary
of the b-file being open and potentially
getting under an attack on that one so
and white at the same time it doesn't
seem like it has a clear path as to
where the castle uh the best move castle
in the position bishop takes f6 is one
of the best moves castle is not an easy
move to make from
a practical perspective just allowing
knight takes g4 with the g-file open
straight towards your king i don't know
it doesn't look like a very easy
practical decision for white so let's
see by the way he played it
he played g5
these kids know everything
are you kidding me thank you i'm
gobsmacked no seriously g5 wow
mishra so christopher plays g4 right
thinks that okay i took my opponent
opening i surprised you i'm going to be
the one dictating this game this is my
name then mishra comes with bishop
before and then g5
and now it's christopher who's thinking
incredible knowledge these kids have
wow okay i understand that from the
perspective g4 by white
what you want to do with this move g4 is
you kind of want to knock the bishop yes
bishop takes g4 you want to play rook to
g
pardon me rook to b1 now that the bishop
no longer controls the b1 square you're
ready to crash through on the b7 pawn i
understand why you wouldn't want to play
bishop takes furthermore i understand
why you wouldn't want to play knight
takes g4 because the knight is necessary
to guard the pawn on d5 and then after
captures on d5 moves like bishop b5
check are
on tap and you don't want to deal with
that so
the two captures of the g-pawn i
understand is bad
but
what about night before i mean that had
my attention right away because i was
thinking
that
i'm frightened of knight c2 check
what would have happened in case
uh mishra had gone for
this line uh christian well actually
knight before unfortunately loses um
a couple of ways to do it uh the point
being that i have bishop e5 in most of
the lines so i should take on f5 first
or i can go bishop e5 first that defends
my rook on a1 and then knight c2 you're
not going to get the full rook but i
don't get the full no you don't get the
full rook because i have bishop e5 and
actually your position just crumbles
agreed agreed that that's that's it all
right so that's why we understand the
move bishop e4 so then after bishop b4 i
i try to break this stuff down logically
in my mind like absolutely so i know
i i had this conversation with myself is
that a good move is that a bad move so
bishop e4 i get
but now comes
why didn't he play e5
i mean because that moved to my mind
that certainly is a logical move right
[ __ ]
gaining
how come it won't let me play even more
what one more click one more click
bishop g2 for white bishop g2 for white
that's that's it so guys
before we get into the trenches in this
game we have breaking news
sophie mori suzuki is winning what
get out of here it's been five minutes
since the start of the round she's
already winning
last night coming out what happens
just happen knight to e5 knight
fd7 came on the board and this just
allows
take on d5 take on d5 with whatever you
want to take take on d5 continue taking
on d5 take on d5 bishop takes d5 what is
your rook doing on a8
itself
unattended knight takes e5 d takes c5
thank you very much that's fine this
queen actually protects the bishop and
you are losing the rook no matter what
you do the best thing you can do is
actually just give up the piece go
knight to c6 and beat two pawns down
two pawns down
at move 10
c takes d5 on the board and right now
let's go to the table to the bird's eye
view because i want to see what vella is
thinking
and whether she just realizes right now
that she's lost she didn't play bishop
bisa she played the move b7 b6
then she does not play bishop b7 the
enchanting the bishop knight fd7 but
instead plays knight after he says she
took it
of course she did we might be crowning
somebody today oh my god
this move knight f6 to d7 is really
reminiscent of bishop
bishop f5 to d7
what jennifer you played yesterday a
total finger failure total
disconnect with the requirements of the
position yes
she failed uh
in her opening knowledge and this looks
like just the same thing a finger
failure uh by black oh dear so she was
trying to exchange the knight makes a
lot of sense knight in the center but
first play the move bishop to b7
required yeah and then play knight fd7
or now that with a [ __ ] 27 you defend
the pawn on c6 you can even just follow
it up with knight bd7 just the usual
knight bd7
it's inexplicable uh this blunder so
early also it's just been 10 minutes
since the start of the round guys well
not just that it's just been
wow
and what
what a situation for sophie to have
she's she's a point in the lead which is
great great great she's trying to secure
her victory but to secure it 10 minutes
into the round wow
that's i feel obligated to knock on wood
right right
and
i just
i i'm kind of stunned again our decisive
number of games
it's just going through the roof and
this is actually one of the things we
have been seeing a number of egregious
opening
failures uh
and here's the fighting chest on round
seven we had
over 86 percent decisive games 13 out of
15 were wins and as we were coming in
you said it could have been 14 and
you're right shibala was losing and the
whole tournament has been uh a huge
number of decisive uh except for under
throne two let's let's put ground two
round two we kind of missed that one but
53 60 80 round four
66 these are huge numbers guys i think
this is historic we'll probably not see
this in the years ahead but
overall out of the 105 games played
coming into this
round
63 almost 64. that's a nice number 64.
64 percent yeah
that's a nice number yeah so it's nice
boy we were we were just breaking down
the game of christopher you uh christian
and then you took us to sophie we just
got blown off course what's going on
with the christian uh christopher you
game once more i i will see what's
happening in that one but first i want
to take you to uh this game between uh
balaji dogopathy and brandon jacobson
and maybe you guys can explain me what's
happening in this one let's go first
let's take a look bishop to b5 a6 bishop
for normal stuff right sure the real
lopez g6 sure a little bit of an offbeat
line nevertheless it has been playing it
played plenty of times i actually played
it myself yeah d4 take on d4 knight to
d4
knight to a5
i don't play this
what you play bishop g7 you go into a
normal line sure you you do something
like knight g7 you go into a normal line
you take on d4 you go into some sort of
a normal line but you make a novelty as
early as move seven knight to a5 take
the knight to the rim for apparently no
reason right it's
puzzling to me i don't understand the
move and maybe you guys can explain it
it's once again incredible how these
players are coming with new ideas these
young guns are just analyzing chess day
in and day out and they're coming up
with this very peculiar but maybe ideas
that currently with modern chess engines
work knight to a5 is the move knight to
b3 was played the knight to c6
is this uh the uh resurgence of a
potential queen to d6 queen to e6 berlin
repetition are we going to see knight to
d4 and then we're going to go into this
repetition let's wait and see but still
knight to a5 such a puzzling i mean
sorry but my assumption okay knight f5 i
would never play it in a million years
but i think my 5 has cl he's like
clearly saying okay dude i want to play
b5 c5 c4 by bishop correct but
it it i mean i feel like white can do
almost anything that relates to stopping
b5 and c5 and it should still work it's
it's interesting so
the best move according to the engines
is actually one that you wouldn't
probably think if you see this uh first
time over the board and that is a move
queen to d2 holy guacamole right so take
on d4 and knight takes d4 knight to a5
and now it seems like queen to d2 might
be the best move now the idea is
obviously to attack the knight on c on
a5 but also to be looking at the
potential queen to c3 taking advantage
of the fact that you played g6 opened up
the long diagonal put some pressure on
your rook i like this move
queen to d2 it makes a lot of sense but
only after you see it with an engine
after c5 knight to b3 white is almost
winning
it seems like because if you take on b3
then i just simply take with a bishop
you have a weakness on a d5 you also
have this queen to c3 coming this from a
strategical point of view not even a
tactical point of view is not good news
for black so you cannot do that
you have to go something like knight to
c6 the problem with knight to c6 is that
i can just simply take take if you take
like this then i can just go into the
end game and once again we see
that this move g6 weakened a lot your uh
position on the king's side and
unfortunately that gives white a
decisive advantage close to a decisive
advantage knight to c3 will be coming
followed by knight wave four you have
some problems with the pawn on c5 as
well and once again the king is lacking
a spot to height
king to c7 will be met by bishop to f4
so
you cannot do that now if you go knight
to c4
yes but queen to c3 you can see it
coming right that's a double attack you
can go knight to f6 and probably regain
your piece after the move b5 but you
know this is not good news and this is
probably what he should have done now
it's a big bluff you play knight to a5
you know that queen to d2 will punish
you if white knows this move and plays
it will punish you you will get into a
much worse much worse position but then
you go to the board and you bluff and
then play the move knight to b3 knight
to c6 right now balaji dagobati is
thinking and trying to come up with a
plan it does seem like it's not that
easy right now b5 is a threat right so
you have to defend against that you can
go knight to d4 but that invites the
repetition you can take on c6 but most
likely this is not necessarily what you
want after d takes c6 it is an end game
uh but it's not as good of an end game
as the one that we previously saw
because this pawn instead of c5 is on c7
and that makes a big difference it's
much more compact for black the position
so knight to c6 this is what we have
right now and you guys were asking also
about the big game of the round
christopher you versus abi manu and he
actually blitzed out after bishop takes
g5 not rook to g8 not knight takes g4
but long castle right this is what we
have right now
complex position we're going to have a
fight guys abimanu
wants to win he still believes that he
could potentially come back in this
tournament and force a tiebreak and win
the event
he still believes and this is extremely
important he's one and a half points
behind christopher yu luckily for him he
has the chance with the black pieces and
this is the best chance and the best
position that he could have hoped for
out of the opening a complex battle with
everything hanging and you knowing the
theory and what you have to do in the
position this is the best scenario for
black for abby monument christopher you
right now
well he must be thinking why did i play
this move g4 why why did i come up with
this blazing hot
approach when all i needed to do maybe
was just to tame the waters a little bit
make a quick draw or something and going
to the last round in the lead that's not
the case anymore we saw mishra there
standing up behind his own chair looking
at the board reminded me a little bit of
david brotzky yesterday hovering around
the position
uh it's upon sacrifice uh christian and
uh how does the engine evaluate the
situation you've been saying
double-edged double-edged double edged
yes and how does it get to zero zero
show me in multiple ways okay
castle is one of them
castle just uh going straight into the
attack um bishop takes f6 is another one
of them okay
again all zero zero zero zero in all the
lines even though you're
most of the lines is zero zero i mean
black has a lot of initiative despite
the fact uh that well actually are you a
pawn up right now yes bishop
yes yes yes yes
but you will be losing either g4 or c4
so
i cannot even really count this position
as necessarily a upon for white uh at
least to maya is especially this pawn on
g4 will be lost unless you give me the
bishop with bishop takes f6 then you
indeed can uh for example if you take
and take on d5 and say yes i will keep
my extra pawn like that by exchanging
the pawns but after bishop takes d5 in
fact this seems to be already a much
worse position for white black has a lot
of initiative even if you castle right
then i can just go bishop takes f3 this
is in fact just simply lost so from a
tactical perspective it doesn't seem
like you have a clear way of preserving
your material advantages right
and uh you just have to accept the
complications and take the bull by the
horns go castle and try to find your own
play against the castle
black king
because you know black is going to play
rook to g8 get on the g5 right and try
to create some pressure like that
wonderful
one of the things that grand masters
always do is shop and compare openings
if you will i want to go back to the
game of bellagi versus brandon jacobson
and that really stunning move knight a5
i remember when i was a team
studying the rui lopez one of the
variations that really had me greatly
perplexed was a line that went a6 b5
bishop back to b3 and immediately
they hunted down this bishop in so many
rui lopez variations this capture of the
bishop for the knight was avoided white
would play a3 and bishop a2 or c3 and
bishop c2 not allowing the trade and in
this case you could see that well the
knight really goes after the bishop
right away and tries to hunt it down you
might say well in this case don't you
leave your pawn on e5 hanging and the
answer is no you take the bishop so
there's no
captures against the f7 and then you get
surprised by the double attack queen to
a g5 hitting at g2 as well as e5 so
the prescribed way
of playing was to play d2d4 allow the
trade of bishops
knight takes bishop and go into this
variation i
spent
a misspent summer no that's over
overstating it i spent a mistake a
misspent week
trying to play
bishop to d5 all right c7 c6 bishop
takes check
king takes knight takes e5 check
i don't know where the king moves let's
just say backwards and i was trying to
do these types of things with
king e7 as well as
king e8 and i had a lot of fun
nobody nobody nobody ever played knight
85 against me
so all my preparation went out the door
now in this particular case we have the
inclusion of the move g6 and d4 and we
shop and compare because now the the
knight move knight a5 to my eyes makes
no sense queen d2
that just tries to refute the the move
right away just tries to re but
if you're if you're looking to save your
bishop you could play either c2 c4 or
you know enterprisingly offering a pawn
or c2 c3 in order to save the bishop and
you make the move knight a5 look
weird to say the least
in the game actually what happened was
balaji went for knight b3
knight
back to c6 bishop takes c6 on the board
uh christian was saying d take c6 is a
slightly worse endgame for black it's
kind of like a
i want to say a berlin with the pawn on
an e5 and also like uh
on exchange roy lopez right yes and also
like an exchange
exactly
and if you take with the
b-pawn then maybe something like bishop
e3 going what if so what can i just call
quindy for now yes queen d4 is a very
standard move and i think in many cases
i'm going to have to play ugly chess f7
f6 i'm just a little bit worried that i
would fall
into some very
dark
place
i don't know if you've ever seen this
kind of a tactic but it's always very
nice when you get
oh that's painful ooh
painful that's a nice word to describe
that situation so yes queen d4 a really
good move
challenging the diagonal with the bishop
as well i think
brandon
took too big a risk
in this game with his opening and
christian what else has caught your eye
well the situation for anne marie vela
against sophie's maury suzuki is getting
from bad to worse from the worst this is
pretty much over this game is pretty
much over and i'm not exaggerating at
this point
oh there's just a piece down i'm going
to take on c6 your king she did this is
literally just a piece down
we've played this round for the last 28
29 minutes right and uh sophie should
probably just uh accept a resignation
any time soon right because the bishop
will drop back i can even take on f6
first why not can we just trade queens
and call it goods yeah you can do
whatever you want
at this point you literally can do
whatever you want you can take on f i
think taking on f6 is just the most
precise just because you take another
pawn right why not i'm going to be a
piece and a pawn up
this is over guys you were saying when
it pours when it rains it pours exactly
and it is raining uh
badly for anna marie here and for sophie
wow that happened this is a gift
that sophie is getting from her opponent
and i told you at the beginning of the
round
anne marie valia is really struggling in
this event only one out of seven points
she's uh
definitely not finding her stride but to
lose like this in only 30 minutes well
she could have resigned 15 minutes ago
yeah it's very difficult it's not a good
look it's not great at all no it's a
very very disappointing uh
game because you want to fight i mean
you you come to the national
championships with the hope of
you know doing a few upsets and you know
feel like you're in the game but this is
like the first ending of a baseball game
and you're down nine nothing i mean it's
just your piece down and you have
absolutely no compensation and as you're
saying christian if
uh if the leah were to resign right here
everybody would say wise decision you
you
you blundered in the opening i want to
turn our attention to the game of andrew
hong and i wonder liang for just
a moment
as again andrew is hoping that
christopher slips again
because he's just on the half a point
outside looking in
and he's playing against the number one
seed uh a wonder and in this position he
played the move knight e5
bishop came back to d6
usually you play uh castles first and
then you decide on this move f4 but uh
harry nelson pillsbury pillsbury yeah i
want to say
from the
late 1800s created what we call the
pillsbury attack oh what was attributed
to him is the pillsbury attack but
that's with this pawns on d4 e3 and f4
um the pillsbury attack was you put your
knight on e5 you castle and then you do
a
rook lift we're actually going to see a
queen lift queen comes over
to
h3 and you're eyeballing greedily this
pawn on h7 so
one of the uh huge mistakes you could
make is thinking oh i've got that
guy protected
let me take this pawn on d4 and white
you blew it you blundered upon
and uh i'm gonna hurt your feelings with
the move knight takes d5 because now i'm
threatening to capture on f6 and then
it's checkmate on the next move your
best move at this point is g7 g6 and
guess what thanks to the rook you're
going to end up a piece behind
in this game so which is explains why i
wonder played g6 to stop knight takes d5
we've got castles on the board
and
at this exact moment andrew hasn't
sacrificed anything
and
it's always been considered that this
type of attack this pillsbury attack if
you will is dangerous dangerous for the
second
player we'll see if the you know the
18th century romantic chess of attack
attack attack uh will hit its mark in
this game um did they teach you uh
the pillsbury attack when you were a
teen
um i said i don't think they did no why
i don't think you're you're missing this
class not very culturation no not very
cultural romanian uh chess school
exactly exactly well in the american
school we had we we had to learn the
pillsbury he's one of the heroes yeah
it was a big favorite especially amongst
class players you'd see a lot of
i want to call it the kali system
with and that's with bishop g5 right
yeah with and with bishop to d3 and c3
and stuff like this e3 b yeah yeah well
i'm going to keep my eye on this one
what do you have for us uh christian
well actually i was just uh looking
through the variations and looking uh
through the games as well i saw that
justin wang versus karissa yip was
actually looking quite similar to what
happened uh in the brandon jacobson but
without the move a g6 and actually with
the move knight to f6 right now and
immediately d4 we know castle is the
main line d3 is also uh the main line
but d4 happened by justin wang and right
now karissa is starting to think bishop
to e7 e5 this is currently the position
that we have on the board and it does
seem like knight to d5 or knight to e4
are the two best moves so this is what i
was looking at
andrew hung versus a wonder liang well
i'm liking andrew's position i really
like this knight on e5 the fact that you
cannot clarify the situation in the
center as easily as black as you would
like it to be and this knight on e4 e5
is going to live there right it's much
more difficult for black to get his
knight to e4 and this is what i'm seeing
i also like this queen already on h3
doing some damage uh
to black's structure in front of his
king and potentially get the queen queen
to h6 followed by rook to f3 and rook to
h3 so i'm seeing
quite an intriguing attack brewing and
this one for white definitely andrew
hong still within his element and i'm
also liking his time situation one hour
and 32 minutes for andrew one hour and
eight minutes for a wonder liang
definitely this is something that andrew
prepared
at home a wonder didn't a wonder we know
that he's not really feeling good about
this tournament he's losing a lot of
rating points and uh he doesn't stand
the chance of potentially competing for
the title right now so he just wants and
he told us actually yesterday he just
wants his tournament to be over and when
you're in that state of mind you're
prone to be the subject of your
opponent's vicious attacks and this is
exactly what we're seeing right now all
right christian thank you for that i'd
just like to turn our attention to the
seniors an event we haven't spoken of
yet because we saved the best for last
of course of course and let's go to our
tournament leader larry christensen
versus alexander shabalov and so what
happened is larry's white and with this
last move by
shabba he's inviting the move d4 d5 a
benoni
which has a reputation
as a very risky defense for black but a
very tactically
sharp line of play which larry said no
not today
uh shabba i am not going to give you the
position you want i'm going to keep it
tight
closed and the players
transposed to a pan-off-bod vinnick
attack with the karo khan knight c3
bishop e7 here
there's a massive debate that is raging
with theory as to whether the move
bishop b4 or bishop e7 is the best
bishop b4 has its
adherence if you will bishop e7 is what
i like to play larry took and quickly
transposed into an isolated queen bomb
position and then
shabba takes a page out of the anatoly
karfov playbook captures on c3 b takes
c3 no longer
an isolated queen palm position because
that pawn is protected but there could
be issues on the c file bishop c4 and
pawn on c3 sometimes you you see black
throwing in the move queen c7 to provoke
the move queen d3 before um playing the
move knight c6 and are we caught up with
the players again this is all theory uh
we'll keep an eye on this one and the
other game i wanted
because how much the players are
thinking especially larry he's down to
an hour and 10 minutes i'm assuming he's
not very familiar with his lines no i
he's absolutely familiar this is um
from the 80s and 90s we're not even in
the tavia position it goes for for a
long long long time i think the reason
that larry has taken so long
is he's thinking carefully about
navigating to the type of position he
wants he's saying do i want to play an
early bishop d3 do i want to play it
with queen e2 and rook d1 do i want this
setup do i want that setup blah blah
blah
one of the great stories was david
brunstein david bronstein uh was a vice
champion of the world he played in the
world championships
just
awesome awesome legendary figure comes
to a game in hastings
he's white first move he thinks for 50
minutes boy
15 minutes on his first move like what
and he wins nicely and then the
journalists reasonably asked david after
the game but mr brownstein why did you
spend 50 minutes on the first move and
david says i was thinking about what to
play
and sometimes uh in your openings you
you slow down you slow down you slow
down and you're thinking i want this
middle game i want that ending i want
this
larry has slow played it to get to a
position where it's a strategic fight
and nobody's doubting shabalov's ability
to attack and play tactically strategic
play not completely his forte uh we'll
keep an eye on this one i wanted to turn
to the game of max delugey for a second
cause what
okay so this is this moscow system
uh i think they call this the moscow
system but okay bishop b3 okay this is
um
from the start
uh slav defense and igor knows this
stuff inside and out is this mosca or
anti-muscle i don't play this as white
or black
sometimes these opening names confuse me
completely as well
it's the anti-moscow
there we go so right here i mean this is
the bod
you take on c4
the amount of dorsal the amount of
analysis from this from this defense
is unbelievable i remember i tried to
learn as a little bit like oh my god 10
years ago and i was like yeah i'm good
with them so exactly but i remember um
uh daniel stellwagen a very very
promising
junior player
from holland we had some trainings
together
and i said daniel what would you like to
look at and he said i'd like to look at
the the bod venice pawn sacrifice
variation i go okay
and he he wanted to analyze this move
queen a5
takes
and b4 okay and this position is
ridiculous this is like a completely
absurd position
because okay first of all the bishop's
hanging second of all the knights
hanging so you've got no no choice you
have to play knight e4
then there comes the move bishop a6
so we started analyzing we started
looking we started looking deeper and
deeper and there are no rules of play
there's no
i should be playing h4 i should be
fighting for control of the d6 square i
should be fighting for to win back the
pawn no it's sheer
calculation i threw dale out of my home
so fast and don't you dare ever come
back don't call don't write
did you pick up a sign no more books
no the sign was no daniel still welcome
allowed i mean it was a terrible
terrible thing and uh these pawn
sacrifice variations are just
overwhelming which explains why uh igor
actually played the move h6 he is in a
do or die situation no
no no not at all igor actually um
uh hasn't been doing that
but on the other hand max oh max he is
the one who really wants to press so he
sacrificed upon this is absolutely crazy
variation as well
uh it's all about who is best or better
prepared and the interesting thing about
igor novokov is that he's got a
reputation
amongst his peers as being one of the
very very best prepared so max had
better make sure
that he
brings it and what do we have here
christian in terms of the theoretical
um
evaluation just also quickly mentioned
the time max is uh almost full so an
hour half hour 29 he's been playing yeah
and
igor is an hour and five minutes so he's
used nearly 30 minutes on his clock
max virtually nothing
and again uh christian uh
how how does
the theory evaluate the position how do
the engines evaluate the position so it
seems uh this move a rook to d1 despite
the fact that uh it wasn't a completely
new move it was something that probably
threw a novikova off because the main
line was actually to go castle castle
which made the most sense and right now
after castle you do go uh knight takes
e5 bishop takes e5 bishop to uh g7 or
even bishop to h6 followed by long
castle and tried to take advantage of
knight to d7 kick the bishop away from
the center and then just play that
position as it is but rook to d1 seems
to have a tron uh novikov off a little
bit knight takes e5 after a serious
thing he decided to take on e5 and more
or less follow the main line and let's
see what happened bishop to ac5 bishop
to g7
b3 i have not committed yet to the
castle take on b3 and this is the
position currently that we have my guess
is that the difference between castle
early on and rook to d1 and then
potentially castling later on is that
after the move castle maybe f3 is right
right now the rook is still on h1 i can
immediately drop it to g1 and put a lot
of pressure on the g file so this is the
big difference and this is what novikov
is trying to understand right now where
do we stand when things open up on the
kingside if you take take well i mean
this is a completely different situation
than what you would have expected to get
out of this opening right because rook
to g1 is coming and it's coming fast and
if i manage to maybe even just sacrifice
on a g7 and then get the queen to g5
on the dark squares you're going to have
huge problems as a black so this is
definitely not something that you want
to see
engine is saying already plus one
advantage but also from a practical
perspective
it just doesn't feel right you don't
want to play these type of positions and
i have to say i'm looking at what
happened what transpired in the game and
it feels like max lugi despite the fact
that also sure he is way ahead on the
clock he also got a very very easy
position for him and a position that
favors his style he likes to play this
type of sharp positions we're going to
see f3 come on the board then right now
i have to say the pressure is on navikov
to stop white's attack so what i'm
seeing
maybe is uh that black has to keep the
king in the center at least momentarily
just play maybe something along the
lines of queen to b6 and later on go for
long castle i think short castle is no
longer an option for a black if he
doesn't want to fall under tremendous
attack by white species this is what i'm
seeing in this game and i have to say
every single game is explosive today
take a look at what's happening in the
game between joe benjamin and vladimir
kopian a copy on one hour and 30 minutes
joel benjamin uh down 30 minutes on the
clock so we see these discrepancies in
uh time situation in most of these games
yes
that joe benjamin has been having some
time management issues
well this definitely does this position
what you've just you're about to tell us
about christian is this is still theory
yeah demonstrative of the
the many many decisive games these are
these are not your berlin defenses
exactly four knights here what's up
the four knights they're they're they're
they're uh swinging for the fences what
is this open i think we get it the way
akopian is looking at this game is
almost as a must-win situation once
again he's playing against joel benjamin
before yesterday he was struggling
nevertheless he won an important game
joel to get him back on track and get
his confidence
back and that's more or less bad news
for akopia nevertheless he's still
taking some chances in this game with
the black pieces
dictated by what he's doing right now in
the opening phase but i'm looking at the
games and i see one the top game is
between melcomian grand and tigran
petrossian well
these two players are armenians and we
know actually vladimir akopion
lived in armenia before moving to the
united states so he definitely analyzed
these type of positions with these two
leading players from armenia so
definitely he has some knowledge
residual knowledge maybe from very old
sessions of preparations uh with these
two players or maybe other players but
right now it seems like he knows the
position better than his opponent and i
mean still joe just playing
one rook to d1 good move
still following that game then we're
expecting queen to c7 very quickly right
now let's wait let's see what they're
going to play maybe we can
there we go then we see vladimir putin
he takes his seat sees rook to d1 which
is the main line
and i'm expecting queen c7 to come
shortly exactly let's see if he tries to
remember his theory if he still knows
what he's supposed to do
but uh this one is going to be a double
strike it's kind of strange to see a
position with three and three versus
three on the king side where
the three for black is not h7 g6 f7 but
it's actually e6 so there's an e6 pawn
and an h2 pawn and not a usual pawn
structure no queen c7 and for the moment
black is uh upon ahead how does white
how
how does theory say after queen c7 white
is supposed to win his pawn back queen
to c7 and in fact right now things are
getting quite uh complicated okay
nevertheless the next move
once you see it you kind of understand
it's uh typical and it makes a lot of
sense it's rook to d4 okay
attacking
before but also getting ready to swing
the rook to h4 and create an attack
against the king taking advantage once
again of the fact that there's no h pawn
and potentially i have an h file to work
with and get closer to your king exactly
your bishop is also pretty far from the
fianchetto square when you see the pawn
on g6 in this type of configuration you
usually expect that black has the bishop
on g7 that's not the case right now so
black has to contend with that as well
you cannot hold on to your pawn at this
point if you don't want to fall under
tremendous attack if you play bishop to
c5 rook to c4 or rook to h4 are quite
problematic for uh black so you have to
go back to e7 and then b takes c3 is a
move you're not going to take back on c3
because bishop to b2 opening up the
wrong diagonal
will spell bad news for you that's so
you don't want to see that yeah
rook to d1 he's thinking
right now a very complex battle once
again joel benjamin already burned
through a lot of uh his time
but we know he can play this type of
positions joel likes to attack as well
absolutely going back to swinging to the
ladies for just a moment in the girls
section we've called this game literally
early but sophie
uh we're expecting to that not only
she's going to win we just kind of don't
even understand
her opponent has resigned shoot what's
worse than worse
terrible bad worser i don't even know
all right
it's getting worse
and worse we can't get worse than this
it's bad it's bad because we first said
the position was bad and then we were
worse and i'm not like english
yeah yeah yeah we we're on the edge of
uh catastrophe here guys guys yes guys
breaking news yes sir breaking news
mishra just blundered horrendously and
he's in a completely losing position
right now
check this out castle castle
knight takes g4 came on the board after
knight to d4 whoops
resignation time
because all of your pieces
are hanging if you take on g2 i take on
g4 with a check
that's obvious and i'm going to pick up
the bishop one g2 i'm going to be a
piece up
what else can you do do you want to take
on d4 sure i'm going to continue taking
on d4 and once again this knight on g4
under tremendous pressure also the
bishop on e4 under tremendous pressure
and once again
once this diagonal opens up and this
bishop uh is taken off the board rook to
b1 with some pressure on b7 will come
and if my bishop lands on b7 your king
is dead you don't want to see that on
the board so
and he missed it
he played queen a oh what's in the water
guys i mean we're seeing so many
blunders
this is just incredible what's happening
on all of the boards right now knight to
g4
and christopher you could have sealed
the deal in this game with knight to b
knight to d4 the engine was saying plus
five
i think he just wasn't even looking in
that direction when you're when you're
castled on opposite sides of the board
like you are
i mean christopher i understand you know
he's just thinking
i want to play rook b1
i want to be able to recapture with the
rook i don't care about the exchange so
i mean sometimes you have that tunnel
vision yeah you have this idea i got to
go queen a4 i got to go rook b1 i got to
attack my opponent's king but knight d4
seems like that short-term tactical
opportunity
he's trying after knight d4 you know
like
let's say bishop takes g2 quit this g
for check
and let's say pawn e6 and then are you
sure you want to open up for your rook
okay i mean but if i move my coin then
my if i move okay easy okay easy i was
just thinking i mean it's it
we have engine so we know it's terrible
and also the position is not very fun
everything is under attack but there is
a queen takes d2 is there
anything that may i'm trying to justify
what christopher might have thought so
that shouldn't go down this route so let
me take a bishop if you'd like you can
take on a d2 what you
say uh let me take a look
any funny 1964 it's legal
thank you
it's good start yeah i'll recapture it
okay i don't think there's
one at some point you're gonna take
right but then you're an exchange we're
talking about material here all i'm i
i'm not talking about the respective
kings and whether or not you have
compensation but you can see that after
i play rook d1 and i take i'll have an
exchange
black's king looks pretty i want to say
vulnerable as well
what
christian was pointing out is just look
let's win material you know let's play
the move knight d4
uh let's take this bishop let's take
this night let's take this knight
but continuing your thought which is
like okay
uh how about uh i take on d2
well in this case if you put your king
here but knight takes knight and rook b1
that's exactly right
so you have to put your king or maybe
your rook there you go
here's maybe more
more along the lines of maybe what you
would like is to say okay
how
terrible bad is my position
okay um i mean i wouldn't wish this upon
myself but
materially speaking i
think i'm just landing against your king
if you take six coming up too right
you're
welcome and
oh nevermind yeah or you can see six is
coming yeah uh yes the g g file is open
but i think good luck using it
well i'm landing the the the the big
punch first but the move queen a4 okay
you tell me
that uh christopher missed a win
christian i believe you i mean knight d4
looks like a short-term tactical
opportunity but
a huge opportunity i don't know let's
let's it's you by the way that was not
the only move
you can also just take on e4 and go
knight to d4 this is plus four as well
that's a much better simpler that's fine
you you don't see knight to d4 or you
don't want to leave so many pieces
hanging that's fine play knight takes e4
and then knight to d4
close to the same thing because this
bishop is going to take on e4 open up
and then tremendous pressure is going to
land against the black king so
this is not looking good but he played
move queen to a4 and right now black
has the opportunity of playing the move
queen to b4 which seems to be
equalizing or at least balancing
the situation one more
time because this is a big missed
opportunity for christopher christopher
in general doesn't miss this type of
opportunities
i i will have to say that queen before i
have missed i mean because when you look
at the move queen a4
optically you're thinking oh my gosh
queen comes to a4 and across the fourth
rank
how many black pieces are there i'm
ready to play
c4 takes d5 and
win
either the bishop or either the knight
by the way again i really really want to
play the move rook b8 and maybe crash
through
brilliant sacrifice on b7 but
unfortunately the move queen before is
rather
that's a show-stopper uh
is there anything else besides going
before i think everything else though
that's got to be losing i don't think
you want to take on f guys i think we
should just go to sophie's game because
we're going to see a resignation
i'm surprised go first no we're finally
forced to see all right
there's queen g5 coming oh okay so
that's just checkmate that's a checkmate
you can move the rook and then i go
queen h6 followed by queen to g7 that's
checkmate um
so let's just wait
to see
the pain
once again guys we gotta see the pain we
gotta see oh i would love to ask sophie
how she feels after this game do we have
a crown handling oh there we go
resignation
wonderful wonderful opportunity
you just i just feel really really sad
for
annie because again she's playing in
this national championship
you want to acquit yourself well this
wasn't a game it was like it was it was
a blunder on knight f6 to d7 and she
could have resigned it almost three
months after three months three moves
after making that that blunder the game
was lost below an hour
good for her this might be the quickest
game that we've seen in these junior
championships right in terms of decisive
results yeah yeah because we've seen
some draws something crazy but
definitely decisive results this might
be the quickest one yikes
this this is really really
not what you want yeah but i mean after
sophie's yesterday lost i feel like she
kind of
is she this is this is a good thing
it's a great thing
i'm happy for her you know like i feel
like it's kind of
she's making a nice comeback i can't
even call it that because there was no
compact no
but i could be in the last place if i
win in 57 moves i'll be on cloud nine
that day i don't need that much
yeah but again
i feel like this was simply a gift and
there's no other way of putting it
a bad game but our congratulations to
sophie as she came into today's round
with a one-point lead and she's looking
at her competitors her rivals her three
rivals and say you guys are gonna win
because if none of her rivals win
she's clinched yeah by by virtue of this
victory shall we take a look at her
rifles and right now so she has a tie
breaks in her pocket yes
sophie has a guaranteed playoffs yeah
now
talia
will need to win today to potentially
exactly keep contact with her and then
win again tomorrow exactly in a big
clash so she still has
her faith in her own hands
if she wins the next two rounds jenny
for you doesn't jennifer you doesn't
have her fate in her own hands anymore
she needs to bank on talia to
potentially create something tomorrow
exactly and she needs to win today
so is rochelle so maybe you guys can
take a look at what's happening
right i've got the game between jennifer
and gracie on my board and again as
we've been saying jennifer uh needs to
win and she needs help
uh from talia tomorrow as well well we
left it we left it more less around
these parts
jennifer
enjoying the advantage of the two
bishops and also in this position where
you're castled on opposite flanks again
it's about getting
to your opponent's king
faster than your opponent gets to your
king i love the fact that with these
double pawns
on
g6 and g7 jennifer with the move h2 h4
starts immediately eyeballing
this possibility of either playing g4 g5
or more simply h5 and h6 i like the fact
that jennifer is
i'm going to say a little quicker
about getting a tour opponent's king
dorset i'm not trying to fail in that
night on f4 just yet i was i mean i
wasn't i was kind of undecided maybe i
wanted to go knight to c3 oh i love the
h4 everything until h4 all good
including knight e2 yes i'm sorry you
you did
okay
the final move of the position okay
here i didn't really feel the knight f4
i was thinking can i just go g4 h5 just
push those because in case i need that
knight to go back to c3 it's already
there but if i go knight f4 i'm making
more of a commitment that
i don't think it's bad but i still
i don't know it just doesn't sit that
wonderful with me okay fine uh what was
your sorry c4 g4 yeah
okay right and i see that you want to
play g5 and h5 and i don't really see an
alternate you see if
bishop comes to you you can cover
that with either bishop c3 rook c2 so i
i see bishop a3 and i think nah that's
that that's not a threat that's any good
so i'm going to try knight a5
with the idea of putting the knight on
c4 and you know on a good day
opening up the c file for i hope
operations future operations uh all
right now how would that how would it go
well first thing
if you take
but then the queen will take yeah
the two bishops
with that trade see one of the days
so you
what i'm saying is that you need to play
g5
h5 before you can open up a file
and
careful
knight
c4 is on my agenda
i think with the move so you like knight
before yes okay i like knight f4 with
ideas for what it's worth
of sacrificing uh the potential for
bishop to d3
knight takes g6 and or bishop takes g6
uh i like those ideas the one thing i do
have a problem though with
is
normally speaking
when i have the two bishops
i'm looking for my two bishops
to bring me an advantage in the ending
nice okay
so any endings i kind of tend to think
of as being favorable for the two
bishops so here
when jennifer dropped back with her
queen and i'm assuming she's doing that
to keep the pieces on the board against
gracie and and so forth uh queen takes
knight takes knight f4 i'm kind of
thinking okay i'm a little bit better
i'll i'll play this but dorset we have a
guess so we're going to go over to
christian and
well i can only i can guess who
sophie uh there's not much to say about
this game what just happened
um
yeah like this opening uh was
something that
i guess i don't play that much but
i thought i would give it a try for this
game you wanted to surprise her early on
in the opening and you definitely did
she played this move knight f to d7 what
were your feelings when you realized
that you can just simply take on d5 and
pretty much get an objectively winning
position
um
yeah i like looked at this um before the
game um
like i think
um there's even like a different trap
with like bishop b7 e4
and then knight b to d7 which is like
i also looked at with like then there's
knight takes c6 knight bb7 and now
knight takes e6 yeah so like there's all
kinds like this is a really tricky
opening in general i think um and like
knight fc7 makes sense if you don't see
that like uh then
yeah yeah
um very nice so there's like lots of
different tricks to this opening um
yeah so i
wasn't really like expecting that to
happen but i thought there was like a
pretty i thought there was like a slim
chance that could happen because it it
does make sense like if you don't cc
takes d5 and i take c5
and you played it fast you knew
what was happening right now you knew
the assessment of this position
now
what are the thoughts that go through
your mind at this point with this
victory you guarantee yourself a tie
break at least
what are your thoughts about that
um i'm definitely a little relieved
um because i was super nervous after
like i lost the last um last round
and
yeah i was definitely like yeah just
really jittery and i just cause because
at that point like i mean i i still had
like
a pretty safe one-point lead but like i
it wasn't as safe as two points
you're definitely not so like i knew
like i had to do well in the next you
know few games so
now we were having this discussion on
the panel how did you approach this game
did you see this as an almost must win
situation for yourself given that
anne marie valia was quite struggling in
this event
yeah i thought like
i like my best chances definitely come
if i win this game
because you have three suitors that are
chasing you closely uh behind did you
get a chance to check any of those games
um
not that much
probably not that much because not that
much happened in those ones you finished
in under an hour this might be the
quickest uh decisive game that we see
here at the juniors congratulations
sophie tomorrow still one more game to
play but we'll let you go get some rest
and i'm sure you will be getting your
popcorn ready and watching the games of
your closest competitors congratulations
sophie thank you wonderful well done
indeed and this is her very very key
matchup dorsa for tomorrow yes playing
versus talia
who is
having a alright tournament she's in
a tied for second at the moment natalya
is two points behind but she is black
against rue yang yan
and
well
pieces have come off unfortunately for
talia who
really does need a win at this point i
see the position unfortunately for her
as being one that is really really
too balanced there's nothing imbalanced
about the position and i can imagine for
example a move like a5 you
don't want to lose the pawn for nothing
and then play c6 and the pawn structure
really is
even with this double pawn if you put
the pawn back on f2 uh it's it's even
all around again this is a position that
talia needs to win it's not a good
position to try to win from what's your
question i was just wondering like
is white gonna try to play d4 or is
black trying to play d5
what can't what can they do about that
center
um yeah when you had the pawns on e4 and
e3 usually
normally speaking the move d4 is rather
a bit of a no-no uh the pawn on e4 tends
to get very weak so for example you can
imagine a just a move like knight to g6
queen e7 and you start thinking you know
what i'm gonna have to go bishop to d3
and defend i'm going to be
put on the back foot on the other hand
as white after for example a5 you might
be thinking oh look at this i've got
this open
file let me do something
with it let me play a move like rook a2
rook f2 and
think in terms of a puzzle rush tactic
go go attacking and one of the other
lines i've always thought these were
funny variations i love
i i've always described the move rook a2
and rook f2 to michael bodwinick i saw
many of his games where he did that and
then i always thought it was really
funny
when people went queen
to c2 and queen to a2
putting the pressure on that diagonal
and that one i always subscribed to my
friend duncan suttles
because i remember duncan playing these
moves like queen
to b8 as black and queen to a7 going on
it's like what
doubling up
making a battery from the side like that
that always
struck me as very funny but the problem
as i see it is it's so difficult for
black to make an imbalance and talia
just played
c6
okay i'm a little intriguing uh she's
looking at queen b6
as a counter player
i is she's trying to play d5 where she's
opening up the queen yes both both shoes
she's she's playing uh
for d6 d5 and to give her queen
an outlet okay i think maybe white can
try to kick away the bishop the pin is
kind of annoying
or you
you do or to get out of the pit yes one
of the two like you could go queen c2
you could go queen d2
uh if the your intent was to
move the knight or get it out of the way
or as you say h2h3 okay so h2h3
um
looks like a decent uh move for sure
um i don't know should i
keep the pin
hard for me to tell wanna i think
you shouldn't be capturing
let's just see this i don't think you
should be
making this trade i could be wrong
do we do it with d5 or we just do it
like this
um i'm not sure i'm still undecided
because i'm thinking if i could get my
pawn to a6 i'd be a happy camper
and
this case
my bishop wow
tough for me to say uh i would require
more analysis i i'm
i'm not sure about this trade but the c7
c6
makes an otherwise dry desert a little
spicy we'll keep our eye on this and
christian
over to you what have you been looking
at
so i've been looking at the senior
section yes guys because we have some
very explosive games i have to say in
that one as well and one of them in
particular i have to say is the game
between larry christensen our leader in
this action against alexander chabalov
and uh this is the current position that
we have on the board queen to g2 just
came
on our relay right now a couple of
seconds ago and it's the best movie in
the position and it delivers a
tremendous attack for white because we
know bishop takes that faith this is
already starting to look like a big
threat right bishop takes a so for
example if you play some
86 move or something along those lines
bishop takes f8 if you take back queen
to h6
and take a look at what's happening
right now knight to g5 is coming and i'm
getting close to check mating you your
only defense is to go queen to f6 but we
look at the position after this this
first of all a6 was a bad move just
because it weakens the b6 pawn as well
and i can go rook to b1 rook f2 uh
b1 but i can just simply go rook e1 or
f2 e1 and just keep the position as it
is ask what is your counter play in this
situation if you try to remove this
knight and get it to f5 well the problem
is whenever you touch the knight from c6
and move it anywhere you want you're
going to allow me to get my knight in
the center
on e5 and this is a big piece for white
knight to d7 is a big threat that's a
gain of an exchange at least also this
knight is getting close to g4 that's
going to allow me to create more
pressure on the dark squares around your
king this position is just looking like
from a practical perspective from a
human's perspective forget about the
engine forget about the plus one that
the engine is giving in the position
it's a very difficult position for black
and uh knight to e7 seems to be
objectively the best move but that once
again allows this move knight to e5 and
you don't want to see a centralized
knight and pretty much all of white's
pieces are starting to work together to
deliver the checkmate or to deliver some
devastating consequences on the king
side wow a game that we haven't looked
at as we just
prepare ourselves to go to break i think
it's a very big game it's between alice
lee and rochelle rochelle me she's one
of those outside looking in i need to
win i need some help but i think alice
has played a magnificent strategic game
right here
when you look at the position and you
just kind of say okay why is white's
position so much more favorable first of
all the knight is on a terrific square
as is your night but this knight on d4
is actually hitting something the knight
on c5 is not
hitting something compare the bishops
the bishop on b7
little passive the bishop on c2 not so
very passive at all uh and we're about
to see the queens uh come after the move
rook c8
very understandable rochelle wants to
patrol the open file but i'm
anticipating alice playing the move
queen h5
if like we see we just saw in the
seniors game
of shabbalov and larry christensen if
you allow
the white queen to post up on the h6
square well you can see a lot of
dark square weaknesses you start to
imagine that there are sacrifices to be
had
even with the queen
on this rank sometimes this move knight
f5 let's make a bad move let's just make
a bad move so i can at least
demonstrate what i'm thinking i can go
knight if i threatening mate threatening
mate i see and now the queen on these
that's your dream position right right
right right so
i'm seeing alice alice
um
playing the role of the spoiler and not
playing the role of the helpless victim
here and queen h5
nice advantage alice lee rochelle needs
to win
as we go on break you've got a key
boutique i do i do honey what's up for
today
i love the sign yesterday the grand
master master parking i think that's
something's gonna come home with me
we'll fight you for it that's fine
um
we do have a very interesting
autographed chess board
so all of the players juniors seniors
girls they have autographed the wooden
board
so it's a very very cool one oh look i
can see up here there
i say oh i see italian
signatures yeah so this is kind of a
limited edition autograph wooden board
it's signed by all of the players
and it does 2022.
yeah i saw that earlier it does have a
certificate of authenticity and it is
exclusively sold at q boutique and plus
dot com
very very nice and as we go to blake
as we go to break we asked the juniors
playing in st louis common light playing
in st louis we'll see you on the other
side of the great
[Music]
how does it feel to once again be back
in st louis playing in this prestigious
event it feels great um this is my sixth
time playing so i think from the first
time i've played to now you know i've
seen a lot of players come and go and a
lot of players still here so
um yeah it's definitely very special
as a feeling just to have
gone from one of the youngest players in
the event to think that i'm the oldest
player in the event so
there's a there's a lot of history for
me and a lot of great feelings and you
know obviously it's always great just to
be back in st louis it feels great this
is my first time playing this tournament
and it's a really strong event and i
think it's a great opportunity for me to
get some experience against all these
great players i'm glad to be back last
time i was here
um it was in october so it's been a
while
um
but yeah very exciting i actually
haven't played juniors in a while now
it's a little bit weird i guess i'm not
playing the girl section like i usually
am
but i'm very excited for this tournament
i'm really excited to be here and it's
my last time so i've won it
and and on a high note
feels really nice it's a tournament i've
been waiting for and it's a strong field
and i
will look forward to playing
definitely very excited
it's quite a
big tournament obviously
and very excited to play all my fellow
competitors it feels amazing st louis is
one of the many places i look forward to
coming back to recently i had this
amazing i had these amazing events one
was a the spring classic group we wish i
won it feels amazing to be back here i
hope my streak continues generally enjoy
i enjoy playing at the st louis chess
club for for several tournaments so
it is always nice to
be here
be
be here and play play tournaments in st
louis chess club um it's a great honor
a great honor and pleasure to be back
again um
my first time was actually last year so
this time just you know trying to do my
best
and hopefully improve upon last year
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
right
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to our
live coverage of this the penultimate
round as we have our first winner of the
day
sophie morris suzuki remember the name
she's at seven out of eight doris says
she's looking good such a wonderful
event yes she is
and she uh won very very early from the
start actually out of the opening as
anna messed up her preparation got a
losing position um across the board i'm
seeing once again
more decisive clashes as
all the players first yeah well just
because david brodsky yesterday uh
really opened up the tournament
um
thanks to his victory over christopher u
i'm just looking at the the game between
david as white and pedro espinosa
and
i mean look at the position there's a
complete chaos on the board it could be
that david is just completely winning
and got everything under control but
whenever you're having a king a po on a
half open file
and you start to see ideas of rook takes
b2 check
yeah exactly you don't just sit there
back and you don't just sit back and say
i got this i got this
you're seeing uh sacrificial ideas after
this move by pedro
d65 and
good luck
i do like this d5 i have to say but i'm
like
the the king side is also kind of upper
grass exactly g6 takes h5 it looks like
there was probably a knight g3 takes h5
he didn't want to capture and open his
position if white has enough time
probably f4 f5 coming up but i don't
know if white does
that looks slow
looks a little slow wanted to turn our
attention to
our tournament leaders because that's
always where i'd love to start this is
the queen
i think it came
i think we got the traded off the board
i'm sorry i just registered this game as
ah white is winning knight d4 will pick
everything up
my apologies i think that's queen a4
happened queen a4 was uh
and uh here was that tactical moment yes
that christian was mentioning that
if christopher had played the move
knight d4
uh the engines were giving white an
advantage of four points and in some
cases even more this was a missed
tactical opportunity but i can't blame
christopher queen a4 sure looks good to
me
to my eyes especially if you open up the
fourth rank but this is where
mishra found the only move queen before
to keep the position balanced and i'm
just going to play catch up with the
players
rook g8
bishop h4 on the board
and well it looks like it could be a
three result game still going on
here this game is going to be so
critical because if christopher doesn't
end up winning it and then he goes back
and like oh no i had that moment i let
it slip i sure did
i wonder uh pardon me andrew hung andrew
a half a point behind uh
christopher needs a victory against the
number one seat that's a big ask a
wonderland
with the black side this was the
pillsbury attack we had seen it up to
this moment and we were kind of really i
was warming up to a white's position
very much i was thinking that
well uh the only piece that isn't
working and if we could put the bishop
on h4
that that would be nice right uh another
another idea also caught my attention
was you know like to maybe swing this
knight around so that i could play
knight to f5
at the cost of peace i'd be willing to
sacrifice the move i didn't expect is
what came up right here after bishop e1
i was somehow expecting a pawn sacrifice
maybe it's no good
he takes and for a pawn you've got a
pretty unpleasant pin you've got ideas
of of sacrificing uh against uh
the g6 square he didn't do that he gave
up his powerful knight or rather traded
his powerful knight
and well a wonder did not want to see
the move bishop h4 uh arriving he played
knight h5 are truly annoying that's what
i like even beginners in beginners the
first thing i tell them don't let
opponents pin you and keep it there and
keep getting opponents
and i feel like after knight h5
the position is not
[Music]
in the favor of just white suddenly i
feel like um black is got resources he's
k he's kicking and over to you christian
just to build up on uh that because
you are correct yeah sir this knight on
e5 was doing such a tremendous job so
bishop to e1 may be sure is not in the
right direction but after c takes d4
what i think white should have done
andrew hunt should have done would have
been to not take on c6 and try to
maintain the material balance but
actually take the bull by the horse take
on d4 allow uh yourself to beat down one
pawn but after a bishop to h4 bishop to
e7 and then f5 or e1 and then f5 you're
gaining a lot of initiative with the
white pieces and i think this is what he
should have went for in this game by the
way forget about the engine the engine
is saying that black is better
nevertheless in my opinion at least from
a practical perspective it feels very
dangerous and it will have given white
quite some chances as well so this was
an option for him but let's take a look
at what's happening in this game between
balaji and brandon they went straight
into the line that you guys discussed
bishop takes c6 b takes c6 queen to d4
dorsa's
move very good move f6 was played but
nevertheless
you called it ugly chess yes you called
it ugly chess and it is ugly chess and
not only that but uh the assessment of
this position is also ugly for black
because it's very difficult to get your
pieces out this night on a g8
particularly and then after that if you
manage to go castle you would be fine
but unfortunately it's not as easy to
get there without losing material let's
take a look at how that could
potentially happen bishop to g7 knight
to c3 queen to e7
you have to defend the bishop on g7 and
threaten the move f5 a nice discovery
attack get the bishop out lengthen its
action and this would uh mean that black
would get more or less a fine position
unfortunately white can just sidestep
this idea with the move queen to a4 now
f5 i'm just simply going to take open up
the e file and it's actually deadly for
a black not only that but how do you
continue this position as black if you
go knight to h6 which to my eyes makes
the most sense just get the knight out
go knight to f7 and go castle bishop to
f4 and this is why the queen is on a4
because right now d6
not possible queen takes c6 right right
why i'm uh playing d6 is that the
opponent c7 is under attack right that's
why i played bishop to f4 so if you
castle sure thank you very much i'll
pick up a pawn that's an extra pawn and
i don't see the compensation do you want
to play queen to d8 i mean this is
starting to look really ugly for uh
black you played queen to e7 queen to d8
knight to a5 knight to c6 you're losing
a lot of tempes and the problem is with
best moves and not even the best moves
but maybe the second best moves in the
position
white is developing their pieces uh
smoothly while black is just having very
very big trouble getting his king his
queen side flank under uh underway so
this is exactly what we're seeing right
now queen to a4
i'll give a decisive advantage to white
in this one and let's take a look at
what's happening in the senior section
as well because this is
really nice
check vladimir kopian's preparation and
we were discussing it does seem like he
analyzed thoroughly this line because
check this out
so
after queen to c7 which was played very
quickly
rook to d4 was something that we were
discussing
at this point joel benjamin had 59
minutes
he taught for 20
minutes another 20 minutes and played
this move queen to b5 which is not the
best move in the position we were
discussing about rook to d4 and by the
way we're still in uh the theoretical
knowledge of at least vladimir kopi and
theoretical knowledge probably not joel
benjamin's he played queen to b5 a game
a move that has been played before
bishop to d6 queen to d3
check this out
c2 rook to d2 and now knight to e5
giving up a piece
right now queen takes d6 but check this
line take take now we're taking
advantage of the fact that this pawn on
c2 is so close to promotion and i play
the move rook to d8
you take
i take
and now you're close to resignation
because i go rook to d1 next move and
then i follow it up with knight to d3
right if you try to get away from this
checkmating pattern you cannot go bishop
to d2 because i take on f3 and then i
pick up the bishop on d2 right so that's
big trouble as well if you go h3 i give
you a check then i go knight to d3
that's big trouble as well i'm going to
pick up the bishop on c1 and then
promote my pawn so you cannot do this
the only move after rook to d8 to
continue the game is to drop back to d2
the problem is i will take
take
and now i can take on f3 take on f3 and
rook to d8
continue following it up
follow the bishop up bishop to e3 rook
to d1 is losing
you cannot take because i take and i
promote so you have to drop back to c1
but after this
this position you're completely tied
down you are a piece up but you are tied
down with the white pieces you cannot
approach
the rook with the king because i'm
blocking you with this move f5 i'm not
allowing you to play the move f4 and i'm
just simply going to bring my king all
the way to b3 and at some point i will
be able to sacrifice on c1 pick up the
pawn on b2 and win that endgame a very
nice and very deep preparation by black
via vladimir akopian and it does seem
like joel benjamin understood that
calculated this end game and decided to
go for this move knight takes c5 bishop
takes c5 and rook to c2 but now black
can just simply pick up the pawn
gift me the foundation thank you very
much absolutely uh
sorry dorsey move on i just wanted to
point out the times
yeah joel benjamin has down he's down to
25 minutes exactly yes he's been using
a lot of clowns
and uh vladimir kopian has an hour and
18.
hmm that's
says it all i would say we talked about
20 minutes equals potential upon right
boy yeah he's definitely burned a lot of
his clocks yeah i wanted to turn our
attention to our leader in the senior
section
larry christensen versus alexander
shabala the players have kind of
reached a position that christian talked
about earlier h4h5
larry is
rocking the ramparts or storming the
barricades to borrow from his book
titles
he's ready to sacrifice on a g6 after hg
bishop takes g6
crashing through
uh shibalov had no choice but to get rid
of this oppressive bishop he went bishop
back to fa queen to d2
again eyeing up
teeing up for a bishop takes f8
queen h6
and as um
christian was saying this desirable
maneuver knight e7 to bring a piece over
to the king side simultaneously open up
the diagonal for the bishop
always is going to invite the move
knight e5 and i really really expected
this move knight e5 to land on the board
a la tempo because it sure looks to my
eyes like white has
a beautiful attack going yes you can go
queen d5 threatening made in one i get
that but it's just a temporary threat
and after a move like f2 f3 i'm
returning the punch
with the threat of bishop e4 i was more
than surprised that after
knight e7 larry took and i
i just i had this nagging
feeling like didn't he lose some of it
of his advantage
uh christian
by this
oh he
larry had a different approach
altogether instead of putting the knight
on the e5 square he went
knight g5 is this computer engine
approved it's not no no it's not engine
approved at least uh it's uh not as
strong as what he could have done right
and that was to keep the bish porn at h6
actually right force black to take on h6
uh himself and then just put the knight
on f5 first the point being that the
rakon f8 actually is better placed than
the rookon e8 yes because in a lot of
situations knight takes f7 sacrifices
are coming down the pipe right so that's
why instead of taking on f8 yeah queen
to d2 is now it's fine knight to e7 and
now just go knight to e5 exactly what i
just said yes exactly yeah yeah no and
how did the
how did the engines uh i would
i would give white a very significant
edge actually uh
i don't think that this is an easy
position for black to play
it was very close to a plus one
advantage plus what i would even have
between plus one and plus zero point
seven so that's quite a significant
advantage close to one point advantage
and because of this uh
he
he traded uh he released the tension
with bishop f8 and rook f8 knight g5 and
how does the engine assess this it has
decreased a little bit at the same time
look i'm looking from a practical
perspective a practical lens
right now at the position and i still
see
white on the offensive i'm still seeing
white as the one with more opportunities
in the position right where is black's
counter play exactly that you're still a
few moves away i understand you're
probably going to try to target my pawn
on c3 or c8 follow it by queen to c7 but
i'm just simply going to drop the rook
to c1 in that case
in most instances i have a clear plan
and this is what
white is hinting at i'm going to go
queen to f4 followed by if you put the
knight on f5 maybe bishop takes a 5
followed by queen to h4 it's all about
those dark squares that you right now
don't have covered in the absence of the
dark square bishop still white for
choice nevertheless the advantage has
decreased a little bit from a practical
perspective definitely still white for
choice i love your idea of queen f4
followed by maybe queen h4 so you want
to stop me i want to actually i
definitely i do i i don't like uninvited
guests
and the queen on h6 is a
definitely an uninvited guest so how
about queen c7 let's uh let's try your
natural let's say rook to u1
the africa yeah why not just because i
know you want to play rook c8 and i want
to stop you with rook to c1
yes exactly
and well at some point this
i want to say um
passive
knight absolutely has to jump into the
game should i be playing knight d5 or
knight f5 dorsa i need some help
you just have to come to my rescue here
i like them both it's like you you want
you want your bishop to be on d5 you
want your knight to be on d5 so it's a
fight
for those squares how about knight no
come on yesterday i want to take my pawn
right why take my pawn come on you're
upon ground how do i take your i don't
know knight d5
oh you want me to walk into a pig
i mean you want me to commit suicide i
want you to play some bad moves yeah
yeah
uh-huh we're fighting here we're
fighting for a bad okay i'll fall for it
go ahead knight d5 rook to e5 let's keep
going
look at that bringing all wonderful
post up move
i now this is what i'm seeing this is uh
the type of attack that i'm envisioning
yes fun business
if you take yes yes
i think i'm going to take on h7
what do we think about that move oh you
i
think i'm getting killed uh i
knight e2 check is my soul
solace
you see you have
tricky three too tricky
too tricky let's go twitch
youth
basically unsound you know
just right the youth are here yesterday
finding good moves
uh but no i'm just worried that i would
be walking it i i love your position i
think you can keep those sections
you can keep those sacrifices in your
pocket
i
am not a happy camper here i think that
you've just got me
uh but let's go back to your move knight
to f5 right right well i do want rook c8
rook c1 included but
at some point i have to put up some
resistance
to your king side attack knight f5
knight to f5 i'm thinking that if you
take
i will recapture with my pawn and maybe
my bishop can lend some defensive uh
help
to the position
i like it much better than uh the
position you had a few moves ago so
maybe i did something wrong maybe i'm
too slow with let me wrap c8
well right we're starting with queensy
squeezy seven let me try something else
can we get the knight rolling
how
i was thinking for black maybe black
instead of roxy we could just activate
the knights immediately no but rook says
it was nice though
sorry for black maybe knight d5 to just
start pushing for rook c1 okay just in
case you don't and knight f4 yeah um
you're not afraid of these sacrifices
against your king oh yes i am it's not
blanking it's not here
good point good good good point it's not
like it's not fun
uh
i
i'm fearful i i really am i i don't know
if the immediately i can even take on g6
and take back on g6 right i didn't take
on e6 how do we assess that position
for at two pawns
maybe not enough no i don't think two
pieces you go queen f7 it's not enough
and we kind of losing our uh
our our pieces uh
but are we afraid of queen f4 the
problem is
if i played a move
i don't know like c5 let me let's see
am i losing my vibrancy here
um something like this
is probably
fine for black you are hitting
bing bang once the queen queens get
traded it feels like it's getting much
much easier to play for black well so
maybe instead of how do you feel after
95 maybe bishop e4
okay sorry
i just see pins
knight d5
don't tell me like our colleague you're
into jiu-jitsu oh no no that was that
was just for my pins
that's not jiu-jitsu yes no
some kind of wing chunk
i don't know
wow well okay so this game definitely
keep an eye on the joel benjamin game
i'd definitely keep an eye on
the max the loogie game by the way that
was a game eager again max needing to
win
it blowed up whoa
okay we left it here
right
somewhere around here i believe and we
were thinking uh actually christian you
were mentioning f2 f3 without castling i
did i thought that was his plan they
delayed castle to play f3 but he didn't
exactly that you might be able to
utilize the half open g or the open g
file pardon me
night pack
looks like pretty standard stuff
i'm i'm eyeballing knight e5 knight f6
splat all right well it's kind of
logical pretty forced yeah otherwise
you're just going to get killed
g3 c5 takes
um max is one back as pawn uh
but where did
what's the assessment the first time i
want to do that's black i want to get
the queens off can we just go queen f5
and just be like okay i am
ready to trade queens
okay but okay at this moment
though
would you embrace this ending
how would you like to recapture her
dorsett with the pawn the knight the
rook
um
you wanted to trade
about palms so maybe i can go upon a
four afterwards okay this guy is hanging
this guy is hanging
so
let's take it
i'll put in
if you play f4
i'll go knight d6
and getting ugly
fortunately i've stopped you from
playing knight f5 maybe i should have
taken back what the knights did okay
fair
knight takes um no immediate sacrifices
on g3 h4 don't think so
gift me the pawn
gift need upon knight takes any way to
attack something
okay i give up maybe a rook takes so if
you take the pawn i just take c5 pass
right right now we're talking i just
wanted my knight to look pretty exactly
okay i do have b4 just to slow you down
yes you could defend if you like asics
but don't forget i'm the one
in possession of the open
d file i might land on your doorstep i
agree that white is a little bit more
comfortable to play feels like it but um
besides the queen move because one thing
that you have going for you your trump
is the bishop
so you've got to think if i could get a
major piece on h1 oh well i mean
you're you're a hero right so you start
to think well
develop the knight okay that gives me
knight d4 but it also gives me
maybe knight takes h for
sacrifices i'll drop down and if you
retake also i'll have g4 g3 so i like
knight f5 i mean i think
this is very very double edged but it
might be that
[Music]
also
white might get there first uh
a double-edged game christian but it
feels like white is the first one to get
in his shots how was maps
yes yes uh but still a double-edged game
and
the engine are actually saying that uh
after queen to f5
white has an advantage but it's not as
significant queen to f5 though is very
important
that that
needs to play it right now right now if
you play anything else uh white has a
decisive advantage and in fact knight to
f5 i can just simply pick up the pawn
bishop takes b5 for example okay point
being that if you go knight to d4
unfortunately that opens up uh the
possibility that my queen will land on
g6 later on so gotcha fortunately i
don't think you can go there so
um
queen f5
from a practical perspective
i still like
i really like that
and the same goes for the game against
between joel benjamin another very
important game let's not forget vladimir
kopian is only half a point behind the
leader larry christiansen and his
opponent he is a pawn up and this is my
question for you guys how easy it is
though uh from
my research and what i'm seeing right
now on the board i think this was joel
benjamin's best chance to actually try
to simplify the position and ask the
technical questions from black will you
be able to actually win this end game i
understand we're playing for two results
right now right it's either a draw or a
win for black but how easy it is for
black to make any progress if you do
play the move b6 then that's always
going to be attacked with the move a5
and that's going to simplify the
position even more if we manage to
exchange this pair of pawns for both
sides and be left with three versus two
that's going to get closer and closer to
equality right in my vision uh so
if you do play the move a6 well later on
whenever we're going to start
challenging
each other on the d file whenever you go
rook to d8 i have this move bishop to b6
now that your pawn is on a6 so i really
like what joel benjamin is doing and by
the way this is already an equal
position bishop to c7 rook takes d8 or
even bishop to d4 on the board and this
is actually an equal position bishop to
e3 vladimir kopian everything he wanted
out of the opening you have a better
position you're playing for two results
and you're playing with the black pieces
also only 20 minutes left for uh joel
benjamin joel benjamin
after he didn't know the theory and he
got into a worse position i think he's
making the right practical decisions
you don't have a lot of time
simplify the position get closer to an
end game where the moves are going to
come easier also
give this technical problem for black to
solve how are you going to defend the a7
pawn b6 or a6
each of them have their drawbacks so i'm
looking at the position i'm seeing black
with uh some advantage nevertheless not
an easy game to convert what do you guys
think not easy but uh like you say
whenever you're flying for two results
with black you're happy dorset where
would you like it you saw me going home
are you something's exciting you what
does that you think so uh the maxim
versus igor game yeah
we said queen of five was kind of uh
necessary what kind of got to do and he
didn't do it he went rook on a8 to c8
and what excited you for white
about this move
what didn't excite me
well there's a pawn
exactly but did you want to take with
the night or did you want to take well
obviously you want to want it tonight so
i can put them exactly yeah i just start
maneuvering around
why would igor just voluntarily give up
this pawn knight he takes b5 there's
something on c5 that he can do i'm i'm
well again i i mean the only thing i can
say
uh on igor's behalf is my eye is drawn
to these um
i want to say king side
attacks now
uh one of the things that chilled me
when i started thinking about these
sacrifices is a christian said to me you
know there's a queen g6 oh yes
so like for example if i play b4 and i
go sacrifice happy
over here and thinking checkmate
i've got to be prepared to deal with
queen a g6 check which means that when i
get here and the rook pays me a visit
i will never
never be allowed to
the queen landing on g6 will be lights
out so i think it's rook d7
and
rook d7 wow the knight takes b5 rook d7
is in huge trouble
knight takes d5 i like it i i mean for
max this is
the this is his preparation com a dream
come true
no absolutely that one is
pretty much devastating if he does take
on b5 the engine is giving plus 3.5 with
that wow so that's
quite a lot now
let's go back to the junior girls guys
exactly
take a look at jennifer use game indeed
when we left it we left it about this
move
it was controversial let's say the move
knight f4 and you didn't like it i
thought it was okay i was expecting
gracie to play night a5 and knight c4
she actually went for a move i was
discounting bishop a3 because i thought
it was too easy
for jennifer to defend the the pawn on
b2 and eventually this bishop is
actually just going to have to go
backwards
she didn't want to go backwards gracie
played e5 saying hey look if it's my
turn i'm going to play e4 and really put
you on your back foot jennifer said nope
uh let me attack your bishop the bishop
dropped back
let me attack your queen
the queen dropped back
hey look you're the one who's ruined
your pawn structure let me take take and
you know me i
i laser focused in on the d5 pawn and i
thought to myself if i'm in jennifer's
shoes first of all i really yes i really
really want to play h5 and i can see i
can imagine myself playing h5 h6
doc
talk
you know and getting mesmerized
by this type of play for white i mean
again this bishop is just
fantastical right
but
i've got this weakness i mean
i i i'm seeking professional help but
my weakness is i want to take your pawn
i want to take your pawn and if i can go
knight takes b5
knight b6
that shuts out your queen
it's just all good and i think it's big
advantage jennifer
what do the engines say uh christian
huge advantage huge advantage yes not to
not with knight four actually not with
knight no knight
still maintains an advantage but not as
much uh what the engines want to do and
it makes some sense is to take on e5 and
then follow it up with h5 as soon as
possible so 9595 h5 right and g5 h6
right is exactly the line and the idea
that you are mentioning just soften the
long diagonal and then make use of the
bishop coming to c3 and tremendous
attack on the long diagonal and pressure
if you allow me to do this then yes
after this bishop to c3 or even f4 later
on this is game over right
and it's easy to see that it's easy to
understand that even if you forget about
the engine right it's easy to look at
the position and say yes it is white who
has absolutely everything that they ever
wanted and black doesn't have any
counter play right that's the thing i
mean you would expect when you see a
pawn on h7 weakness on the long diagonal
that black has something on the other
side a black pawn on a2 there's nothing
happening on the other side right quiet
quiet seas on the other side while
there's a storm brewing on the king side
nice not looking good and by the way
knight takes e5 is on the board
excellent she's playing the very precise
and very forced and concrete moves
knight takes if i follow it up with h5
i think race is going down in this one
and i was looking at the games of the
other
suitors closely following behind sophie
and talia is uh well getting a better
position i have to say the rook already
landed on b2 a lot of pressure is
starting to pile up i see the queen
coming to d6 followed by the rook uh
doubling up on the b file and once again
it's all about where is your counter
play as white and i don't see
bishop on a2 very weak i like this rook
on a b2 i like the pressure that talia
is right now applying on her opponent
and let's take a look at the other
player with five points that is rochelle
wu with the black pieces
well this is different right this is way
different than what we've seen much
calmer waters right now bishop b7
definitely making good impression very
nicely positioned on the long diagonal
uh
the only problem for black is that you
move these pawns in front of your king a
bit too much right e6 f6 g6 at some
point you're going to have some problems
with your pawn structure at the same
time it does seem like this is a complex
position if black manages to get the
rook to g5 and play the movie e5
destabilize the knight from the central
position and put some pressure on g2
will potentially be better so all of
these
three players that are closely behind
sophie mori suzuki could potentially win
in today's round and that will put a lot
of pressure on sophie mori suzuki's
shoulders as well as talia's shoulders
because she will be playing with the
white pieces in the last round in a big
clash against our leader
blowing up the standings this uh
penultimate round round eight uh we
gotta give a shout out to our colleague
uh women's grandmaster sabina foyza who
is managing all of our social media yes
and we always enjoy it of course when
she passes along
some wonderful questions and uh dorsa we
have a few as our audience wants to join
the discussion see oh youtube user d
bo sport i'm sorry
for sister
thank you of course i think it's about
you now yeah zero one played the pier
but it's rare to see
it's now in tournament play well okay
they're asking why is that and
why do certain openings fall out of
favor i love it because it creates
asymmetrical positions and so do i
i love to uh i love the perk defense
and it's one of those openings that come
like many that come in and out in
fashion
and it's also like one of the king's
indians so i love to fee and shadow my
king side bishop create a fortress with
my king but
people who are playing the bononi and
king's indian and perk defense give up
the center and today the engines are
saying
well it's really a big advantage white
so at the very highest level
i think all the top players play perk
defense just as all the top players play
kings indian but when they play in the
candidates
you don't see a lot of perks
and that's just the way it is
but
just because the top grand masters
aren't playing perk defense doesn't mean
that if you're an expert master class
player and it's your favorite defense do
it don't worry that magnus carlsen has
refuted the dragon you play the dragon
defense play the dragon defense come on
i have to say i have so many kids who
are like i've heard karaoke it's such a
cool name i want to play it but i'm like
oh
no no you don't want to play it
wait a minute i love the garage you
can't do this to me
oh thank you very much
but like um
beginner intermediate level it's just so
so hard to get them to understand the
center development where the pieces go
and like
and they're like oh yeah i've looked
into king's indian let's play it i'm
like alright show me how you play it
show me a game we'll talk about that
like oh no i've just heard the name ah
now you're going no no no no no no no
every time that happens you you've got
to do some action exactly i asked for it
show me 10 moves show me a game we'll
talk about it so one of the things i
like to do especially in the class
you know your class b c a
in the class is find a defense that you
kind of suited like for example the
alekhines defense
no you put it in the engine the engine
will say minus one after 12 moves or
something like that no no no no
you study the alakine defense you make
it your favorite and it's a very rare
bird not a lot of people play the alakan
defense so when you play it you're
surprising 90 percent of your opponents
yes and usually
they'll go for a tame variation because
they're afraid
that your knowledge will be so greater
much greater than theirs that they'll
they'll they'll climb down from the
critical moves so sometimes
go around
give yourself a big reputation as you
know like hey man i'm the i'm the expert
in the alakin and oh he's the expert in
the helicopter let's avoid the
allocation so build that up for yourself
find a defense that suits
your style your taste and
be it be loyal what do you think coach
uh christian
no absolutely and especially for uh
beginning uh players you should play
things that make you happy right this is
quite important because uh if chess
doesn't make you happy then you're not
going to be able to see uh improvement
you're going to hate it and then you're
just going to quit pretty much
that's the progression that i'm seeing
from a lot of players actually just
beginning so
forget about what magnus plays forget
about sure these are trends right but
these players have been experiencing
with so many uh options for the past 10
20 30 years right just see what you
enjoy playing see what type of
structures you
like to see on the board physically just
see on the board and if you like the way
they look if you understand the plans if
you can find a player uh that you look
up to and you see him as a model player
and then you like the way they handle
those positions well you can go for that
forget about how sound they are from
like the 2800 uh level perspective
forget about that right i remember a
quick uh great story we had
in holland uh yaroon paquette
he was a really really top player 2700
and
great talent going places and
the dutch you know rallied behind uh
their junior hero and
gave him a lot of training money and
sent him to a training
with juan victor korchnoy
yorune paquette loved the king's indian
defense
with as much love of the king's indian
as
victor had hatred
for the king as india
after two weeks victor convinced yaroon
paquette that the king's indian was
unplayable
but then yurin thought well if i'm going
to play chess and i can't play the
king's indian i'm going to quit
so he quit exactly
he quit
he couldn't do what gave him joy in chat
that's the joke oh okay he did quit he
did quit come back uh
well he's now retired but uh uh it it
was uh you know
viktor korchner
robbed him of his favorite cherished uh
line of defense and yeah it was just
wasn't this funny no
we have a result wait i don't think we
will draw we weren't including i think
just won that game against malinitsky oh
no big blunder came on the board wow
what a destroyer by dmitry gurevich and
that gets him back to five points by the
way that was a huge victory for dima as
he kind of just like whoops i've got
wait i'm okay
and guess who he's playing tomorrow it
can't be
larry christian larry christiansen oh no
with the title potentially on the line
the script writer's dream as well
as we again are gonna see
potentially we'll see what happens with
larry's game against shabbat but it
doesn't matter the title is still on the
line because even if larry wins he will
still be within striking distance and
here it comes
this is such an easy easy blindness so
the idea is
white igor has just played this move
rook c1 and in white's vision which is
rather a tunnel vision
the rook is not defended
with this move rook c1 white is
threatening a discovery and what's
really crucial about this discovery
threat
is the fact the king is on f2
if the king was on g1 there's no
discovered threat because the rook would
capture with check
so igor had very craftily set up a trap
undoubtedly in igor's mind
it was required by dimitri to drop back
with his rook to defend this rook dmitry
overlooked igor's threat
dimitri just moved his knight back and
igor said
i win
i win knight takes d5 you cannot take my
rook with check it's not check i'm
taking your queen with check and dimitri
said excuse me i know my my rook isn't
defended but if i take your knight
defends the rook oh boy and igor went oh
dear i just blundered a piece
and resigned yeah
a gift
and a second gift
uh christian uh
what do you think will blunder a piece
next
[Laughter]
i'm not a i'm not betting anything on
this tournament the number of decisive
games that we have witnessed in this
tournament obliterates everything i know
about tournaments my only explanation is
that he's getting late in the tournament
right right
played a long game yesterday he did a
very long game against the longest game
of the tournament
energy zapper exactly exactly this is my
only explanation that i can find right
now and i think it's a very possible one
and again with this victory that means
that dimitri is currently tied with
larry christensen larry is still playing
larry has five larry could get to five
and a half potentially even six but
dimitri is giving himself a shout a shot
for uh the
championship round
wonderful and larry is he's not winning
right now
larry has a difficult position against
chabalo
right now uh he did play the move rook
to e1 and now we see this very good move
and this was actually the move
recommended by the engine as well the
move h6 wow i was looking at it and i
was thinking no he will not play that
that's right that's kind of suicidal at
least it looks like it's almost suicidal
weakening the king side even more but in
fact it's actually just the best movie
in the position go for the pawn
yes sir you would be happy with this
decision knight to e4 or knight wherever
and now just simply take on h5 and play
this position open up in fact the g file
and maybe even consider
black to be going for an attacker
h8 and look to g8 so
things are getting interesting in this
game and things would could potentially
get even more interesting
if
he takes on e6 right that's the thing
takes e6 exactly but that opens the
possibility for pretty much anything
happening in this game take take and i
understand you're putting a lot of
pressure here but
i have my own attack in fact on this
side i have this bishop looking down the
pipe to the pawn on g2 this knight
starting to swarm around the king queen
takes h6 sure rook to c7 i have a lot of
defenders as well things are getting
wild
things are getting wild in this game and
we usually see larry with a lot more
time than his opponents not the case in
this one 32 minutes for larry 36 minutes
for alexander chabalov
very intriguing fight and you know larry
is looking at knight x e6 right now no
question about it i i mean if i played
the move h6
to quote victor korchnoy with trembling
hands
because
you have to calculate very consequently
the series of sacrifices 96 knight takes
f7
bishop takes f5 and you have to
calculate all of these sacrifices and if
you're confident you play h6
but with trembling hands because you
might miss something uh that's
i i'm grabbing h5 right away if the
knight moves backwards so the knight
goes to h3 or the knight goes to e4
let's see and larry yeah big decision
right now coming where's that the times
of the players um
36 minutes for shabol off 31 minutes for
larry okay because again uh larry has
been playing a la tempo
and has
has been pretty good at staying ahead of
on the clock uh here he's slightly
behind and
he's hesitating
he's not ready for
knight takes e6 just yet
so the the previous um the the blunder
game that's we just saw the dimitri
the way that they tried to you know give
up a night and get their rook i have
another game who they actually succeeded
in doing that
what game is that
and we do actually sorry uh
definitely don't don't don't don't uh
leave the story hanging
um but uh christian with a special guest
we are indeed with the new co-leader at
least until that game between larry
christensen and chabot of ends that is
dmitry guravich dimitri welcome back
what happened today it seemed like a
gift was uh given to you merry christmas
gift yes
you know i played once with alexander
onychuck who has a great sense of humor
and i made some some very aggressive
move but not a good one and he said that
it was in i think in seattle in the
early 2000s
and he said
uh when you made this move i wanted to
resign immediately
which didn't mean of course but you know
it means that you're not supposed to do
things like that so i was thinking that
watch out for knight d5 but that said no
no bishop on the five can't do that i
mean the under no i don't see any
scenario and i can do that um so it was
just a blind spot from here
but i got you know when you when you
blunder it usually one situation is not
so great
so i think i'm not so sure i want to
check it up but uh i think that my
passion started getting
not maybe a little better oh absolutely
yeah i was because before it was it
wasn't it wasn't the case you were not
worse at all after knight to e8 that's
for sure yes but before he played rock
hc1 i'm not better definitely it's a
tough position if if it's a little bit
it's but of course
according to my understanding yeah
dimitri well this game uh has only one
story but tomorrow there is a big game
against larry christensen in the last
round how do you feel about that game
what is the strategy going into that
game i i don't have too many
too much a strategy i would like to play
a game i would like to fight
uh you know if it's possible because
yesterday it wasn't the fight gregory
out played me very nicely and won the
game and he played very well i didn't
play but
but
and he's a very difficult opponent for
me he's very strong and his difficult
opponent for me uh but i know one player
who is even worse for me but
unfortunately he's not playing out
tournament he's sitting in that room
nice
to back i again
still completely won positions i was
very lucky to have them maybe we'll be
able to coax him into the event
next year just to watch him but
every year we're trying the same
strategies maybe we'll be able to get to
him at some point about larry i enjoy
playing larry larry
right now this is a great game because
two wild players two attacking players
attacking players very rare occurrence
because people want to play position
again
even the best players like yes
you can don't call him but let's ask you
about this position actually what do you
think larry will do will he take on e6
or will he go knight to e4 okay i'll
tell you this i doubt about 94 which is
possible it might be a good move but
again
you know larry
he wrote the book
you have to consider right away knight
takes a six h takes g6 and knight xf7
which probably doesn't work but
something similar something might uh
it's kind of
uh upsetting for white to play kind of
disappointing not upsetting to play
knight g4 kind of because also you
sometimes some simple moves like bishop
takes f5 kind of might be a good move i
doubt it but it might you know so my
impression which is i during this game
by the way i didn't see it other games
at all
i think it was a good decision
to
do distracting but it was very
interesting um
i would
expect something oh
he did he did take one he didn't know
it's just it's it's an analysis it's
just an analysis
we're still waiting to see what his move
critical position critical position and
h6 is putting a lot of pressure i have
to say on larry only 26 minutes for him
we know that he's thinking about that
move knight takes e6 but
yes it might not work and it might and
it's kind of then he had to play knight
g4 and then black
might play g5 probably and
create a nice
normal position
at least from a psychological uh point
of view if you do have to play uh knight
to e4 yeah and don't abide by your
instincts well unfortunately it's going
to be difficult for the remainder of the
game dmitry thank you very much uh for
joining us yes say something about this
we have a tournament it's rare uh people
who we can call
attacking player it's a reactiveness
because it's extremely difficult people
they will play rook f1 f2 think for one
hour then play rock of one of two and
then suddenly sacrifice we have three
people in this tournament which we call
attacking player
it's definitely
larry number one it's definitely
shabbalov
they're taking a lot of pressure they're
taking the root of this and definitely
nick but nick is not in good form so
i compare them with my students i
compare them that a regular player is
like a horse rider
but attacking play is like a bull rider
so you have to sit like 10 seconds on
the ball but it's extremely so it it
was like 8 000
uh professional or half
semi-professional horse riders it was
one only one thousand bull rides it was
like 20 years ago so compare them they
take a tremendous chance but it's pretty
enjoyable to watch them you know
absolutely absolutely and they work fast
that's for sure i'm not in the taking
place
you have one more round you're
temporarily convinced okay thank you
thank you thank you wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute dean edema take it
easy relax first of all i loved your
analogy between horse riding and bull
writing speaking of bull riders tomorrow
you're going to have this big game
regardless of the outcome of larry's
game today just tell me how you match up
with larry i know over the decades you
guys have played in plenty of u.s
championship events what's your score
the story which is hard to uh i always
think about it because that is for me
the most interesting guy to play you
know uh first when i came to united
states
42 years ago
and larry was
already a very famous guy he played gold
junior championship got second place at
that time and he was
um
at that time extremely strong in 1981
one of the was one of the best players
in the world you know
no doubt about it he played on daenerys
he made eight out of 11.
uh tied for biscarpuff he lost a game
against him he shouldn't lose it and he
beat great players boris baskey
grigorich what was you know uh sports
you know i mean he was he made out eight
out of 11 he was he was amazing so
in my first game against larry in us
open he just showed me
the highest class he beat me in position
which was no worse for me but his he
made some trick which i didn't see and
then that was classical and game
gigglish fisher when uh
official analyze a few hours he didn't
happen and he couldn't find uh the raw
and i did the same thing in years opens
analyze the whole night but it was rock
and g pawn against uh
rock which is which is uh it was
unfortunately lost but nothing could do
and then
i thought it was just basically
impossible to beat him at that time uh i
remember once i made the drawing and the
rock and pawnee was two points down but
there was a position
from a theoretical draw so i said oh
it's like to be in a game against him
then i accidentally beat him in san
francisco 1987. if i didn't beat he
would be win the tournament so
but but his score was absolutely great
again against me so uh draw was like a
win
but then something happened i got lucky
in the game uh in one game and then
in this championship i beat him a few
times in a row
you know lucky
not very lucky and once he landed the
rock but i realized it's uh my knight
was going to be something
then i realized it's actually a common
blunder it's like bereaved the same
thing the knight was on youtube you put
rock on the one so i thought okay i
would like you but not dead like
something and then finally i won in 1996
i won a nice game against him it just
was kind of but it was a really good
game it was my one one of my best
by the way in 1996 we had a tournament
seven participants from this tournament
out of ten played in 1996. except of
novik of courier the nation country
vladimir putin who was of course a young
guy but lived also in a different
country and max lugi didn't play in the
tournament because he was working he was
working in a bank but seven people
played the tournament and it was very
interesting how they played it and that
was one of my best tournaments because
if i accidentally would beat uh uh
alexis last time i would be a champion
you know it i was better at one point
but it was
great we kind of had much more chance to
win that again than me but alex simon
unfortunately he's not here but i see
molina's keep on it anyway so larry is
tremendously uh interesting opponent uh
even if you don't beat him whatever you
know which is hard to beat him he's a
great great player one of the very very
best
and
uh
i i remember that he couldn't beat me
for 22 years it was called i couldn't
believe my eyes you know and then
finally in 2010 my last u.s championship
he just crushed me he showed me that my
understanding of sicilian very far
from
you know
perfect
from the other good guys huh
so
by the way sicilian now is not doing
very well and i'm so glad that i don't
place a city anymore in this tournament
because it was the last chance i was
sure that uh my opponent eager played
plays a force it would be sicilian and i
thought oh so good no certainly dimitri
uh big game tomorrow will let you go get
your rest get your preparation going and
get ready for the big clash yes yes
thank you very much yes thank you dima
and we did see and it
larry was hesitating and fighting with
himself the whole time but we did see
h7h6 and knight h3 and demo when he was
speaking he said well if the knight goes
back knight e4 or knight h3 g6 g5 and g5
came
i'll allah tempo if you will this knight
on f3 def h3 pardon me definitely does
not want to stay stay there dorsa we're
going to see f3 knight
sorry can we take that night and
just
at least mess with the pawn structure a
little bit and then
ah maybe rookie five rook to e5
uh don't forget that your knight is
still
uh how do you say uh out of commission
really much so you
i i think you're
you haven't solved your
uh crucial problem um the night i think
it's all about the night if i get my
pawn to f so like for example you just
play f3 if i get my
i mean you know this bishop is going to
kind of lord over the board
you know i don't think you're going to
get escaped necessarily with a perpetual
check again it's about the dual with the
minor pieces bishop takes
um
f5 it's kind of one of those things i
i'd rather keep that in a band like i
don't think the knight is running
anywhere
right uh the big question for me
is can i essay the move i think that
this is a
i'm over playing my hand
so to speak when i play a move like this
because i'm a little bit worried that
the queen i'm inviting the queen to land
on h4 i'm getting a little scary that's
scary so maybe f3
knight back to f2
but
excuse me uh still a three result game
in my opinion i don't think white is
better i don't think black is if bl if
black is better i don't think it's by
that much
yet we'll keep our eye on this christian
what do you have for us well actually i
was looking at uh one of the junior
games that we have that one's the
christopher u versus abi manu game
because wow a lot of things have
happened we entered this end game and we
weren't sure of how to assess it or also
how the game will continue will we see a
quick draw in the end game no this is a
very complex end game that we have on
our hands and let's take a look i think
we left it all the way here after queen
to
a b4 and the exchange of the queens and
let's see what happened knight takes e4
knight to d4 makes a lot of sense
eliminate the bishop on e4 rook to g8
it's all about will white be able to
crash through pick up the pawn on e4 and
open up the long diagonal before black
can set up its attack on the king side
this is the big question rook to d7
rook to b1
e5 knight to f5 check the sequence out
knight to d3 and now c6
don't allow the knight to come back to
c6 and at the same time defend the pawn
on b7 what the c6 is doing you are
sacrificing momentarily the pawn
nevertheless you're forcing this pawn
from b7 to go to c6 so once i take on e4
i will have a clear target that knight
returning to c5 will not be able to keep
a hold a very stable hold of the queen
side so b takes c6 i really like this
move by the way c6 and then king to h1
of course you cannot take on e4 because
knight takes f2 comes on the board and
that's a big problem also knight takes
e3 is another big problem that's a
discovery check you have to get off the
g file with the move king to h1 first
and now we have knight to c5 f3
forcing matters on the king side forcing
the opening of
this bishop and now rook to g6 was
played but this was the passive defense
defending the pawn on c6 makes a lot of
sense abhimanyu doesn't feel like he's
in his greatest shape he lost yesterday
he's more or less struggling in this one
he had a big opportunity right now to
take full control of the initiative with
the move rook to d2
he could have played the move rook to d2
now
the problem is you can take on c6 but
after rook takes h2 you get checkmate
right this is a problem
not only that but you also lose this
pawn then you have to go back to h1
otherwise there's all sorts of discovery
checks despite the fact that you do have
some pieces around my king you don't
have any checks absolutely no checks 97
i take everything is protected by my
pieces you cannot do that you cannot
take on c6 so you have to defend after
rook to d2 with the move bishop to g3
defend the pawn on h2 the problem is
that once again i'm the one dictating uh
the momentum of the game knight to d3
attacking uh the king side and getting
ready to play the move knight to f2 this
would have given black tremendous
chances to potentially even win
this game he did not do that he played
the move rook to g6
bishop to g3
bishop to d6 this is what we have right
now but what does he have ready
to take c6 rook to d8
but this was just a pawn you haven't
gotten anything you're just simply
getting outplayed what if i just simply
drop back d5 where is your attack right
you still have the f7 pawn that you have
to guard
it's not looking good
rook to g6 bishop to d6 it just seems
like all of your last few moves the last
sequence of moves for black doesn't tie
together very nicely and we can see that
bimani is not happy about at this
position yeah things seem to have gone
south as we and he's reaching for his
bishop is christopher you are a
tournament leader
he's played it eyeballing the pawn on f7
as we get ready for break you were
telling us a story oh um not necessarily
the story i was just walking around the
the games uh we did see a blunder and
gurevich game yes the piece yes
but the purpose of giving up the piece
was to win the wreck
someone else but i should do that
win the rook uh in the junior games uh
balaji versus jacobson let me bring that
up on our third one one more okay
the last one the last one jacobsen
back a few moves yeah just tell me when
uh keep going forward now
okay keep going forward
a little bit more
a little bit more
and here
there's your discovery discovery
so the queen of
pardon me the queen on d4 attacking uh
the rook on b2 knight to d5
uh brandon was forced to capture the
knight
and he is in a position
at all
he's an exchange down
and
white has a
powerful initiative yeah this should be
a winning position for bellagi a very
uh
unusual uh opening sequence by brandon
he took a big risk in the opening not
paying off yes and as we go to break i
think we asked uh
the lady players yeah the lady players
about their preparation
and how they
studied for these national championships
we'll see on the other side of the break
enjoy
how did you uh prepare for this event we
know it's a very prestigious event what
was your training routine coming into
this event i've been actually very busy
this summer i've taught a couple of
summer camps and
overall just you know spending time with
family but i've tried my best to still
do some chess work and play some
training games and things like that and
hopefully
hopefully my training shows at the right
moment during the tournament i've played
a few tournaments before this to like
kind of get back into in-person chess so
well i'm trying to be physically and
also mentally fit fit so not only um
like solving puzzles reviewing openings
but also just exercising and relaxing so
that i'm ready for long tournament
that's ahead um before this event i
played in the world open and right
before that was philadelphia
international both in philadelphia
so i didn't really have that much time
to prepare so basically as soon as i got
the invitation i started like
researching my opponents and like trying
to see what openings they played um i've
just been looking at some of my
opponents games trying to figure out um
sort of how they play what their style
is what their openings are that kind of
thing i played two tournaments before
this they didn't go that well
so i'm just not thinking specifically
about preparing just for the tournament
i mean when the field when the parents
come out i'm obviously going to prepare
as much as they can but i just really
want to
try to play the best chess i can
just the usual preparing um making sure
that i am ready to start my games
it's been a little erratic
because
i had college this whole year except for
one tournament that i played but it did
not go well i mean i've just been
playing games and checking what my
opponent played my opponent's plays and
stuff well i mostly just worked on
reviewing my openings i've looked a bit
at the players but not too much since we
don't know the colors of what order i'm
playing the players until tonight
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to our
penultimate round of these u.s
championships girls juniors and seniors
and guess what we have sophie morris
suzuki with a stunning performance of
seven out of eight as she won dorsett
early yes yes that was such a
wonderful day for her
and
would you like to take a look no i was
just gonna say the seniors we have a
result let's go for the senior results
as uh mr gorbach did have a
pretty gifted
also
definitely he was as he said father
christmas came early today as eager
blender a piece and demetri now finds
himself tied for first
and everything to play for in uh the
juniors i just brought up a game just
because it looked like
everything blew up in this game between
david brodsky
and pedro espinosa i mean i'm looking at
this rook on b2 and it's such a visual
as a black is just dreaming of
sacrificing his rook on a2 and blasting
open the king the last move
of david bronski was queen f6
potentially looking for a perpetual
check
and
giving his
saying to his king you take care of
yourself i'm going to go try to make a
perpetual check but i'm looking at this
rook on b2 and i'm trying to find a win
for black i think it must be there i'm
just having a little difficulty dorsev
you can clear the cobwebs for a second
because i mean the desired queen takes
c4 all right let's start with that right
so you're threatening checkmate
okay and i'll go check now let's say
you're playing for a win as black so you
don't want to play king g7 so you're
gonna go bishop e8 say you know take my
bishop
and
you've got no perpetual checks but now
you got to deal with this guy right
so let's just go back and let's assume
i'm not taking your bishop i'm going to
leave that in a band so i'm going to
play for d7
make two queens i got to go bishop here
now where's the win i'm saying rock
takes b1 queen c3 a little tickle for
your king and that's why
i've got to leave my queen on f6 so we
go back to the game position queen takes
e4 oops sorry this is the game position
and i start with the move oh well i
start with the defensive move bishop
here and i'm thinking to myself
i gotta win i gotta win i gotta win
and now
[Music]
i mean i i feel like this is a 1200
puzzle rush tactic and i don't even have
a clue as to how i'm supposed to win the
one thing that you always say is always
look for checks first right yes we did
miss one check instead of bishop b one
what if we went the other way
bishop takes h7
after queen c4 yeah bishop takes h7
let's do it
okay so that's a check so i gotta take
if i move my king i'm actually walking
into a little bit yeah checkmate i gotta
had to draw that arrow
and then well my first thought is maybe
take on f7 f7
there you go that's
we at least got a perpetual
we do have a perpetual indeed in this
game and and you're right it's at least
because maybe with the move g6
uh we actually end up bringing big guns
right
good good good good okay
i i feel like uh we're we're
we're on track here we're gonna give
this position more marination uh but we
have a result also in the seniors i
believe wonderful so we heard that
kaidanov did win his game beautifully
done we were looking at this game i
think we're talking about it i believe
mr girvish was also saying that nick was
not having the best tournament exactly
so
and
uh gregory yeah for him
this is back-to-back victories because
as as dima said
gregory played a really very very nice
game against him dima and he felt that
gregory uh
who by the way is our defending champion
uh was a very dangerous opponent i'm
just going through and we counted him
out guys
unfairly right now he's half a point
behind
the leaders going into the final round
given that larry christiansen is still
uh playing right now so let me think
nevertheless who is he playing in the
last round maybe the producers
could tell us
they could never share that kind of
insider information just thinking about
three-way ties just because i have to if
larry
loses today
and then larry is playing uh guravage
tomorrow they're at the same point they
would be the same point right and if
they draw
kaidano wins if my math is correct it
will be a three-way five and a half and
kaidanov is playing from what we're
being told malnitsky with the white
pieces
a player that is struggling in this
event so definitely good chances to
maybe score a hat-trick in the last
three rounds for kaidanov wow that's big
development because we had him on the
show yesterday and
he was saying that okay this is over i'm
not playing for a victory in the
tournament i'm not going to win this one
but he's creeping closer and closer now
it all depends on what's going to happen
in larry christensen's
game if he does make a draw i think that
puts him at five and a half and he will
be playing against uh novikov who has
five now that means that kaidanov is out
right in the last round no matter what
the result is so he is looking at the
game right now of larry christensen
versus shabalov and he wants larry to
succumb
shabalov right now for him to have any
chances to still win this tournament
exactly just looking at the game between
nick defermin and gregory kaidanov this
was a situation
and a demon was on the show talking
about aggressive attacking players
talked about shabala and larry as two
nick defermin being a third but gregory
said just a second just a second let me
raise my hand i can sacrifice rooks
rook takes f5 and look at this
combination queen h4 guys yes we we have
another result oh
maxine lugi finished his game against
igor navikov and he actually won
very nicely maxim lugi
won and he's right now on five points as
well so another contender
is showing his stride right now wow and
in
tremendous fashion check this game out
check what happened here we left it off
and we didn't expect this game to be
over in six moves from now right knight
to b5 queen to e5 bishop to d5 bishop to
c4 rook to b8
rook to e1 queen to f6 bishop takes d5
rook takes b5 bishop takes c6 how many
pawns do i have extra right two pawns
can you take on e6 yes you can but
unfortunately after queen to c4 the rook
is under attack rook takes e6 uh coming
on the board and breaking through this
one is just completely dead and igor
navikov said enough is enough i've seen
enough congratulations you got this one
and max dloogy goes to five out of seven
big result for maxim to be honest a must
must-win situation for him ah let's take
a look uh we're seeing all of these uh
rivals and uh leaders fall let's take a
quick look at christopher u because
christopher
is now two pawns ahead against mishra
and winning what happened to my pawns i
don't know
i'm just saying that uh it looks
terrible when we left it we saw the move
bishop d5 and we already understood
misha was losing yes and my apologies i
was still thinking about that beautiful
black crook on the second rank as a side
variant that we were looking at
potentially never got there yeah the
rook never got to do too pretty mishra
just didn't sense the opportunity and
after bishop takes e5 rook b6
christopher u
uh said look i'm two pawns ahead and
after this move rook f4 it's just over
it's just a terrible night
to d2 on the board
okay one of the things is about these
nights
is whenever the knights do not have when
they're not supported you keep attacking
them and you drive them into oblivion
yes that's what i'm smelling
you play a move like bishop to c3 and
you say to this knight where b1 the one
and then we make it to suji and probably
not the only move but domination of the
night the squares that the knight could
move to are all
patrolled by the bishop and this is
this is all she she wrote bishop c3
i think is going to
force well resignation might
not be too strong but it's definitely
terrible terrible and with this win
christopher keeps his lead going into
the championship round
another we have
did we see bishop d4 or bishop c yes he
chose bishop c3 and by the way let me
just when we came back on air i had the
game of david brodsky
uh in front of me and now uh
uh
whoa
pedro what just happened to pedro we
queen f6 and he dropped back with the
queen
that can't be good that can't i mean
good
uh oh g6 the other one is over guys but
that's not the consequential game for us
the one that is very consequential is
the jennifer eugene okay standing for
you versus gracie persona because
jennifer right now is just simply
breaking through
check the king's position now check the
h file being open and i'm going to be
able to check my team just a few more
moves now
if you do take on d2 i take back on d2
and that actually helps me because i'm
getting ready to get my queen to h2 once
again you still don't have any play
going against my king while i have
everything going against yours king to
f7 try to escape doesn't work finally my
rook on b3 is doing something picking up
the b7 pawn with a check you cannot go
knight to e7 you have to go uh you
cannot go king to f7 you have to go
knight to e7 but once again i can take
on b7 not only that but i will sacrifice
that exchange for uh the knight on e7
and then take on d6 and deliver the
checkmate this one is pretty much over
we are going to see a resignation very
soon by gracie prasanna which means that
jennifer gets one point behind her
opponent and as we can see jennifer it
does feel like she's not even at the
board she's relaxed she knows what's
happening and she's already getting
ready for tomorrow's match now talia
as well putting a lot of pressure on her
young opponent roo yang yang
and could potentially get a victory in
this one as well and get one point
behind the leader what do we have right
now
well after queen takes a4 we're going to
have equal pawns but
it's about the quality of the pawns and
my a pawn my uh well actually we don't
have equal pawns i forgot there's no
more f2 pawn i was looking at the
position and i assume that there is a
pawn on f2 no more f to pawn
this is what we have right now white is
actually upon down also having to fight
against this past pawn very far away
from the action from the theater of this
position and i have to say i'm looking
at the position i understand
the engine is saying that is very close
to equality but i'm looking at the game
i see knight to h4 coming attacking the
pawn on g2 coming on the board it's not
looking easy for white from a practical
perspective i feel if i wouldn't have an
engine in front of me that black is
close uh to win to breaking through
that's not the case but don't give don't
put too much weight on the computer's
assessment in this one i still feel like
talia is on top and we could potentially
see a fiery finish in the ladies section
as well red hot and deep but once again
just to remind everybody
jennifer has to win
talia has to win and then
they're one point behind
sophie
and jennifer is going to hope that talia
wins
and that will get one of the playoffs
and that she wins and that's how uh
sophie gets caught but in the meanwhile
sophie has been playing great she won a
very easy easy easy victory today and
there's no guarantee that talia is going
to
win tomorrow it's true and sophie only
means a draw to this absolutely the
title so she has draw odds if you will
and christopher is uh you know looking
at the position thinking oh i might get
the title to dave right
no no no not so fast christopher because
check what's happening in the game
between andrew hung and a wanderer liang
andrew hong is right now taking over
this game out of the blue we did not
expect to see this but it seems like a
wonder got tempted by this pawn on b2
and took his forces away from the action
on the king side and right now this
opens up the possibility for why to just
simply play the move queen to f3 attack
target the pawn on f7 you have to take
on uh c2 you don't have a good way to
defend in fact that pawn and after queen
takes f7 king to h8 bishop takes c2 okay
i'm getting closer and closer you give
me one more move i'll take on g6
followed by queen to h7 that's a
checkmate coming your way so you have to
eliminate this knight but
this position the knight on g7 is
completely out of play i understand you
have one check but where's the follow up
right king to h1 where's the follow up
it's not looking good
one pawn to the good for white bishop
versus knight good bishop versus bad
knight i have to say
i'm looking at the position and if he
manages to find move queen to f3 which
is not a very difficult move no to c you
just got attacked by the e8 you might as
well find the counter chance counter
attack queen to f3 comes on the board
we're going to see this one go uh most
likely in hung's way and that will also
take us in the last round still very
closely behind a big race brewing
between these two players
christopher you and andrew hong
yeah and christopher again we think that
he's got the game one against mishra
he's two pawns to the good he's just
activated as king has christopher he's
played to move king on h1 to g2 to f2
and he's coming over to e2 because he
wants to eat this knight on b1 which is
kind of stuck
on the uh b1 square so king f2 funnily
enough i had actually expected king
f3 i'm not exactly too sure why
because i had rook h4 in mind and i just
wanted to protect my pawn king f2 was
the movies played
looks like christopher is uh cruising to
victory and uh dorsa we have a very
special guest wonderful
maxim congratulations welcome back to
the show an important victory for you if
you wanted to keep touch with the
leaders how do you approach today's game
and how do you feel right now i feel
good because i actually i just checked i
played the perfect game which is crazy
i've never played the perfect game
before
because actually during the game i
thought black had a draw but actually it
says i'm plus 15 in that case so i guess
not a draw but i actually learned a new
opening system for this game
you know my opponent just plays
basically two different systems and so i
decided i'll uh
definitely
you know learn and just try to catch him
and i actually found a quite an
interesting idea which was only played
like eight times with rook d1 no
actually this early queen c2 earlier
yeah it's normal to castle but if you
play queen c2 the issue is the the black
takes on d4
uh there's actually some beautiful lines
uh queen c2 and the queen takes pawn uh
we just play right d1
and after let's see queen c5 castles
the problem is that uh
there are no no normal developing moves
like for example bishop g7 gets killed
by knight g6
and then
and e5 yep and not even e5 bishop d6
first and then e5 now bishop g6 first is
like completely crushing
and then then e5 and then goodbye uh so
so black has to play so if the black
can't take on d4 he he's reduced to
number to some
limited things for example what he did
which is uh
you know he played knight d7
rook d1
takes bishop takes and on bishop g7 it's
also possible to play f3 also
a very dangerous for black but i decided
to convert the game into to transpose
that to the line that
that is unpleasant for black which is
after castles castles this position if
black spawn was still in c4 and and
white had opponent b3 then there are
other options for black like knight d7
or something but but
uh
but but now he's already committed
himself to taking on b3
um yeah and b yeah here on b3 black has
other options yeah like b4 maybe but
maybe most likely like knight d7
or knight yes some weird things and then
to actually not when black takes on c4
to take back to play b4 and take on h4
it it's complete complicated but uh
but black has more chances to equalize
but the way i played now we were
surprised about is that uh b3 take a
castle yeah you decided to go castle
instead of f3 yeah well
both are good you analyzed f3 as well i
analyzed both uh but castles the problem
with councils is he's played knight h7
against golden i think in this
tournament in fact like some years ago
but after the nation bishop g3 is the
key move very bad position so he had
this position before numerous times he
said i only saw one game but but he said
he had this position numerous times it's
a bad position
and and uh i mean maybe it's playable if
black plays perfectly but uh you have to
really you know you have to really try
right but he played 98 in the game after
thinking for like 40 minutes so he
obviously remembered you know some some
flashbacks at this point he spent uh
30 30 minutes yeah because they don't
because because of the move order
because he wanted to he was like um i
don't want this so then when i trade on
g7 and play five
okay this is an issue like okay the
problem is if i don't know one line i
saw and maybe it doesn't work i know you
have queen h4
and and queen takes pawn here
uh 94 98
uh i thought i play some move like queen
d2 for example
to come in and if he plays let's say
uh f5 now well he goes here then f3 and
then yeah
but if he plays f5 i play knight f6
check
yeah maybe the queen has to be on c1
sorry queen on c1 not queen d2 but the
point is that knight f6 g3 queen h3 rook
fv1 so and and bishop and bishop f1 yeah
yes that was i mean i don't know if that
was good because you know what do i know
but um but it seemed dangerous anyway uh
yeah queen h4 knight e4
98 queen c1 and let's get to the end of
of this game because a lot of games are
finishing up right now okay let's let's
put it forward yeah yes let's get going
with the moves from the game okay so
uh take stakes g3 stakes yeah here i
thought i i thought he's okay but but
but i'm completely winning it's crazy uh
i thought he played well i was kind of
surprised about ruxin i thought 25
immediately but queen f5 was the the
right move instead of rook to c8 yeah
the only move and then black is like
just worse right a little bit worse but
probably holding on with perfect moves
okay very very difficult
i mean yeah it looks horrendous but but
yeah a night yeah but here she thought
queen e5 b4 knight f5 and and i was like
oh my god should i take it no this move
is just but it's 97
well
yes but knight f5 well no knight five i
thought the frog d7
uh
yeah knight g3 no but queen h7 no no not
knight sir no then i thought uh
wait what more bishop c6 yes bishop c6
and i couldn't figure this out if rook
where if you take it fro k7 then takes a
knight d4
queen h7 check wait still meet huh
that's something
that's still there okay so somewhere
some night move before that uh okay so
that didn't work okay so that so
but he did not play that move he allowed
you to uh
so he basically just resigned with
bishop d5 it's basically the resignation
because like okay now what are they
what's the compensation max uh first of
all congratulations you're back in the
co-leading position at least until the
larry christensen game is over who are
you uh facing tomorrow uh shabalov
shabalov yes so interesting
that that's a big one definitely but
importantly is what he will do today
against larry christians and we'll let
you go back to the hotel okay watch that
game get some popcorn going and get
ready for tomorrow all right
congratulations max as we have
three decisive games in the seniors it's
like
the seniors they're
just they're dropping like flies and the
the decisive the number of decisive
games just is going through the roof as
we see once again gregory idonov getting
the best better of nick defermion with
the black pieces to score four and a
half points
wow
but we might be seeing a result very
soon in the game between christopher and
abi manu because yes the rocks just got
exchanged i was looking at that and i'm
like ah
we should jump to that because i think
we're going to see a resignation soon
with christopher you and by the way if
that were to happen and it's going to
happen pretty soon i believe uh it will
be the first result in the juniors
yeah with more um
decisive games i mean i'm looking at a
wonder liang he's in trouble
i'm looking at the game of david brodsky
against pedro
and uh it looks to me and we have a win
nicely done good job for david
and christopher uh
you has just played a
tsuji move
uh i love that move bishop to c3
against
mishra and this looks
terrible
and again there's christopher yu our
tournament leader
who
came in
with a loss in the previous round
uh which spoiled uh just a terrific
result but he still
with a victory today will uh
being clear first going into the
championship saturday game and i was
also taking a quick look to see who he's
playing tomorrow he's playing carissa
yeah lisa and we haven't seen chris
speaking of justin what's up
versus chris
but i i it was a few minutes to come it
looks like a kind of a the position is
devolved into a crazy
rook and pot end game with
everything is under attack one two three
four one two three four but
i like to play and there's that one and
there's that one
everything is up for grabs very nice uh
first impression is carissa is
definitely not worse
and that maybe she's
interested in exploring
her winning potential here again with a
game with justin wang um
i was again i wanted to
uh
this was the
brandon jacobson but no it was the david
brodsky david brotzky has just won sorry
a wonder
um
when we left him
oh my goodness he didn't play
the move that you suggested christianity
did not queen f3 just looked so natural
to
eyeball that pawn on f7 that was just
weakened he played queen d
does that spoil things it does it does
it spoils the advantage oh no
right now uh rook takes t2
is possible well rook takes c2 because
my knight is hanging i have to get in
the inter meso exactly i think he was
tempted by this potential and of course
king h8 queen h6 that's a checkmate
right that's a lovely pattern yep but
you can just simply go king f8 okay then
i will recapture the rook i presume
yes
hoping for
good no no cheapos nowhere
nothing not checks
well
i mean i can go queen e3 if you take it
with the bishop
if i take with the bishop you could go
queen e3 and we go into the same game
how easy is that it's just for sure i
mean but that's just equality right yes
that's a perpetual you do have a
perpetual if you want okay that was my
i'm not going to go to e7 i think that
was dorsey
like
can we
can we try to force things but black is
not trying to win no okay absolutely not
black is on the defensive end and he
needs to survive so
trading queens is maybe giving black
uh
letting black off the hook so i'll play
queen takes c2 but now queen d6 how
how clear is this position now well is
that an exchange oh that's an exchange
what if i take on d4
queen takes d4 check okay you go queen
f2 that's another pawn
there's another one you go queen g3
i'm not sure i'm happy
and how is this position after
maybe i can even exchange right take on
g3 and take on e8 with the king and you
don't have bishop takes g6 at the end
even that i don't think you're winning
it no yeah can you take ca that's two
pawns for the exchange i should be fine
i would agree
so the move queen d2 is actually just
uh
very bad i can feel like the advantage
is slipping right well slipped or
slopped away
i'm not even sure how to describe it but
maybe just
it disappeared yeah yeah it it did
indeed but
look there's still some pressure yeah
there's still that knight lingering
around the king from a practical
perspective still it is white who should
be preferred and by the way he played
queen to d6 not trading rooks not
trading okay wait a minute
wait a minute what is this move can i
just check and pick stuff up let's let's
ask the pertinent questions absolutely
let's do it
so check i
could
a wonder be preparing a queen sacrifice
and he's only getting
a rook and a knight
i think that's what he wants but
that's well
he's done it
knight to f6 his own oh he took that
instantly he didn't even he didn't even
think twice
when he played the move queen d6 he was
anticipating this queen sacrifice but it
sure looks
as if
it was unnecessary what do we think
about this uh
this trade
if my knight if black had his knight on
f4 i'd say go for it with the knight
still on g7 i would assume it's good for
white
so there is
there is this move d5 right now
d5 yes wow
d4 d5 okay
i was mentioning a moment ago transfer
that knight magically to f4 and i'm
happy camper the movie's definitely the
reason why d5 puts the kibosh
on that idea let's start with the
obvious let's eat
exactly bishop takes d5 now i eat the
pawn on a6
okay let's eat that guy everything with
temple right that's
that's the reason of playing the move d5
you just want to get some speed some
momentum into the position
before the knight comes to f4 we do have
another result
but he did indeed win that game against
brandon jacobson i have to say brandon
with that
knight to a5 idea in the opening a
stunning move knight a5 did not get
rewarded i mean it smells like tilt
knight a5 that just feels like tilt to
me you saw it here first uh the
what are we going to call this one the
and variation i mean i don't know
the the brand in defense
i think uh
there was a grand master from croatia uh
kojou who continued to play a line of
the sicilian and it became known as the
causal
suicide defense
well i mean it was like wait a minute
i wanted i won against causal in that
variation you were one of the
there was a long line of people behind
you uh christian i made my last uh gym
norm in that tournament actually
really it was a european championship
right time ago and were they calling it
the suicide i don't know how they were
calling it i just knew that cause was
playing that all the time and i prepared
something i caught him out of the
opening and it was all she wrote pretty
much but night day five by brandon that
was taking way way way too many
liberties he got punished today our
congratulations
uh to uh belaji for his victory um where
would you like to take us dorsey oh boy
uh let's go back to the ladies okay
um
we have jenna it's been a while since
we've had this looks really really good
for jennifer yeah once again natalia's
italians
my slow girl
wait
and she did play by the way that whole
variation that christian was prescribing
rue yang yan played bishop to b1 trying
to save her bishop talia is not aware of
the fact that the engines think the
position is balanced she played the move
knight h4 and like christensen christian
said
uh if i had black's position i would
think i'm winning i mean it's an extra
pawn right queen to c3 and wait a minute
um can we ask as we say the pertinent
question what happens if i take this guy
it looks edible but i don't think
is it edible
how edible is it rook takes g2 now of
course i would love to come back and
it's not edible it's not edible oh
why d4
queen bee bishop d3 bishop to d3
and
uh out of cheapos in the words of jackie
gleason
i don't have any
gosh you could go queen to b8 but once
again i take on h4 and i defend at the
same time on h2 oh man that is hurtful
just when i had a checkmate
uh landing rook h4 defense uh a pity
which means
that i have to play a move
i have to
uh
pull back my horns and play a move like
queen before
by the way that game with justin and
carissa did end as we expected in some
kind of a a drawn rook and pawn end game
carissa not having a great tournament
uh got a couple of draws but had some
winning positions including against
brandon and she just had no time and
right now she must be clinging on to her
only desire in this tournament and that
is to play spoilers tomorrow exactly
again she plays christopher for you
sometimes when you're having these type
of events in which nothing goes your way
you try to find reasons
to play on and to give your best in
preparation as well as in competition
and that is right now her uh reason of
being of uh playing in this tournament
to play spoilers tomorrow against
christopher yes in the 18th century
tournaments in the early 19th century
tournaments to keep the tail enders the
seller dwellers if you will uh in the
event they had these big brilliancy
prizes and i mean big
brilliancy prizes so even if you were
having this terrible tournament if you
came to the last round like carissa
tomorrow and you played the brilliancy
of your life you could pick up 10 20 30
000
the equivalent
in those days so that was their way of
keeping you in the game we'll see what
karissa brings tomorrow and how
ambitious she is but more results dorset
let's go for it before we start talking
about the yaw surprise you're right
uh david brodsky did win his game
against petro uh espinoza thank you very
much not at all
it was a beautiful game
and
oh yes
blogging yeah bolaji's game was man
brandon jacobson is 985. i'm still not
very
uh you're not a fan not a fan
let's go one more
wow the results are coming in and this
was the draw i think with carissa right
justin and carissa wow our producers are
so fast i know as soon as it finishes
boom exactly
wonderful uh it was a draw between
justin wang in korean saip
and now again we were still on the
jennifer game we didn't really finish it
it just looks like white has some kind
of a a checkmating sequence i would
really
love to put my pawn on g6 and slide my
queen over
pardon me dorset where would you like to
go stop right yes to begin with
but you're just looking for the killer
now
yeah that's the killer shot
i wanted to just maybe play cheap and
play queen d4 but queen david
okay you're a trade queen yeah you're
two pawns up yeah i mean it this
strategy of trading when you're ahead
has worked for oh about 1600 years
so yeah no i mean that's really really
good sorry with talia we didn't see it
oh
she did not play queen to b4 by the way
she defended her rook with the queen to
b5 kind of encouraging bishop t3 i'm not
sure why i don't like that the knight on
s4 is defenseless i mean
i feel like that knight is overstaying
his welcome a little bit
mm-hmm has only three minutes on the
clock that is also true
and
how about tell you how much time does
she have um eight minutes
okay well so they're both getting low
and which number of moves
okay
okay the pressure on more on white and
and
yeah and on the other hand again i'm
looking at the position from her point
of view
her trumps or what you just described
the knight on h4 a little bit offside if
you will as well as undefended as well
as
a passer
so
you want to do like two things at once
you want to push your pawn to d6 and you
want to play bishop e4 and contain this
knight and keep your pawn on g2 defended
what would you do
i would play bishop e4 myself but how
about yourself torso d6 is winking at me
d6 but i love it i see that the g2 is
being problematic though so i might
take care of itself who the heck
you know uh go for it that's my game
exactly
the problem is knight g2 or rook b rook
g2 doesn't scare me i may even play d7
maybe what scares me is that i missed
the opportunity to put my bishop on e4
and defend g2 so i'm thinking i start
with bishop e4 and the big critical
question for me or if i go f5 is what
would i do if you go f5 would i leave
the bishop hanging and say go ahead and
take my bishop and expose your king
let's just take a look i don't know if
it works
something like this but maybe you can
start with queen c8 first because i have
queen d7 right yeah in that position
queen c8 first this
whenever you get a pattern like this
this hurts uh but what happened after
king
what f7 still go d7 now d7
queen g3 was queen to g3 okay
she didn't play bishop e4 still the best
move in the position all right queen g3
is the best move best move yeah start
with can i eat that pawn knight takes g2
and that's the problem your knight
you're so happy you won a pawn but ask
yourself
of all the squares on the board where
would your knight
least want to be and
yeah like somehow you're kind of in the
way of things yeah so knight takes g2 d6
undoubtedly
and bishop e4
i'm thinking this is crazy um christian
but this is a game
where nerves
time trouble
and quite frankly three results are
possible absolutely absolutely three
results on the board right now i mean
knight to g2 bishop before your knight
is lost also
even i think that's the easiest okay so
you can basically resign at this point
so no knight you cannot touch that pawn
so
i gotta defend the knight perhaps maybe
with the move g5
and that's the problem
a little bit
yeah g5 is a move um idea of rook takes
g2 the rook is more
incisive maybe queen to b4 could
potentially i like queen b4 actually
just due to the fact that it creates a
very serious trap
a trap
f4 okay sorry oh no i thought you were
going to go for a
now i go well i can do that i was
thinking about going to d2
even but rook takes me one is it's nice
yeah he's nice he'll take the bishop
right yeah give me the bishop exactly uh
okay so
lots of tactics
um
that double-edged situation
uh
queen before i i'm okay g5 that move is
also on tap as well so exactly a lot of
things could happen but as you mentioned
guys after g5 or queen to b4 or anything
of that nature d6 is the big question
right and that's the that's the counter
play uh well all the excitement that's
going on here let me just check in with
the alice lee rochelle wu game because
again rochelle
is in a position where she's saying hey
i'm competing for first and she's better
in a rook ending
well it's oftentimes
the games are drawn
because even when i'm more active it's
not enough
uh
i just compare kings i compare rooks and
i say okay black's better can she win it
that's a different question but
this king on h2 by alice is not playing
any role in the game and
it's still
you know you're a long way from putting
any um
i want to say material gains up on the
board but g5 g4 g3
some mating chances some mating nets uh
i think it's going to be a draw but
rochelle
rochelle is definitely for choice
wonderful and again um
what other crucial games
are there christian well in the senior
section actually joel benjamin versus
vladimir kopian this is what you have
right now and we were discussing at the
beginning of the end game we were saying
that if we do exchange the two
the two pawns for both sides on the
queen side then we get into this
position most likely white has great
chances to make a draw and i think
that's still the case first of all why
not just put the pawn on g4 and stop any
sort of f5 business he decides against
that still what i'm seeing right now is
a draw i don't see vladimir kopian
unfortunately for him winning this one
and that means
that larry christensen and let's take a
look at what's going on
in larry's game right because we got
into this end game and it seems like
anything could happen right you do have
a majority as black on the queen's side
that could become very dangerous if i go
a4 followed by b4 that a pawn could
potentially uh be
a deadly weapon for a black at the same
time i see the knight on g7 it doesn't
make a very good impression so it does
feel right now that black is playing
without a piece and if i manage to
involve my knight into uh the attack
knight to d3 followed by knight to c5
i'm starting to like wise chances it's a
matter of
tempes right now so let's take a look
and maybe analyze it on your board what
do you guys think about this position
and let's take a look at uh
the players as well because they both
are under well actually shabalov is
under five minutes 3 minutes and 42
seconds
larry christensen still with 5 minutes
and 54 seconds on the clock putting some
pressure on his opponent right now his
last move a3 what do we think about this
move now it makes some sense right a3
because the plan for black was to
destabilize the bishop from b3 without
a4 right
a3 i like this move
what do you guys think
uh feels like seriously
thanks to the double rooks on the e file
that
shabalav
and his king are really feeling the heat
um
and from white's point of view if larry
can get in moves like g4 takes f5
followed by f5 to f6 he'll simply
checkmate
uh shabbalev's king so there are threats
and they're very very severe this move
a5
like if if larry had made a
a decision like capturing on f5 the
problem is the bishop will uh
lose its connection with the pawn on d5
thanks to a4 that's why larry played the
move a3 move we
like and then we had another move rook
to d6
attacking the pawn on d5
okay now that's first
yes exactly they sure are
okay i don't see it quite yet
takes on f5 takes on d5 i don't have
some brilliant tactical breakthrough
with d6 you're not obliged to take
my pawn you could take my bishop now we
understand if the pawn were on a2
this would probably be a winning
position for black for white for me so
let's keep going with that variation yes
um
f6
no bishop takes d5 first bishop takes d5
rook takes
6. now f6 and now the desired check
without the bishops on the board
have i missed my target take take
take around 38 sorry rookie 8 king f7
force and now rook to e7 not knight to
g4 rook well knight g4 i'm worried about
knight takes f6 clear sorry
i mean even in this position i don't
actually see the follow-up but
let's try it out rt rook takes e7 um or
king takes f6 or king takes i was afraid
i was walking into a maid i'm not
walking into a mate i'm not sure
i don't know dorsa i feel like there's a
mate here right you you you think you're
just uh coming to the promised land uh
what do you think i mean it looks scary
but um that king is also becoming really
that might be it yeah i mean uh this
position looks good
wow at the same time
yeah no this uh this bishop takes this
probably doesn't work so this is the
current position we don't have to take
on f5 we could defend the bond
if none of these tactics work but i tell
you
moving the king off pardon me moving the
rook off at the e file is not a move
that will come easy to an attacker like
larry he doesn't like defending even
good pawns uh on the other hand rookie
one if you take
you're encouraging 94
as well as takes
i think this is great for white right so
maybe it looks great yeah i think maybe
i should just
not go for anything forcing but maintain
this this wonderful pawn simple chasse
simple chest just d1 i like it
and that creates a big threat taking on
f5 followed by a knight to e4 now taking
advantage of that rook on d6 not greatly
placed exactly i really like the rook on
b6 this rook to d6 doesn't make a good
impression on me exactly well a crucial
game and again dorsey if you don't mind
just tell me the uh times from what i
see uh they're both uh around three
minutes so larry
whoa he's down 50
something seconds how many moves 242
whoa whoa how many moves 2 3
and they need five more moves and he's
definitely one and again this is not
larry's nature but
he overcame his reluctance he played i
think the best move
uh but only after looking at the
alternatives very carefully um
what is the computer's evaluation at
exactly this moment uh christian
no
zeros no
how
but that's not the only move
the point being that you want to
exchange uh these rooks you want to
exchange a pair of roofs at this point
and try to
get a breath of fresh air in the
position for black your pieces were kind
of stepping on each other's feet now
that you exchange especially this very
active rook that was putting a lot of
pressure on the pawn on f5 this is the
right way to continue let's uh wait and
see and he played this rook he said
there it is very very quickly
and knight d3 in response also very
quickly i like that that might have to
be activated it was time that's the h3
knight right right it was
it was terrible on h3
once it landed there and wanted to it
wanted to move again
knight to d3 on the board again i see
this is a three result
three results game still a three result
game guys
absolutely and especially with this time
situation right now
and once again uh the joel benjamin game
for those of you following closely
against a kobe and okobian is a half a
point behind larry
he is looking for shabala to do some
damage against our tournament leader
larry christensen who is enjoying a half
of a point lead coming into the round
but at the moment he is in a tie with
dimitri gervais there's a lot of players
that are looking for
some damage
a lot of people are in their hotel rooms
looking at this game right here right
larry
larry a lot of players are uh are
rooting for shabbat this one right
rookie seven knight d3 on the board and
the players are down to three minutes
one minute and thirty seconds for
chavalo take it back one minute and
thirty seconds
and again uh
engine
engine recommended move take on g4 take
on e5
yeah take only five and king e7 just um
keeping the tension get the king
involved in in in play taking on e5
knight takes e5 king e7
is considered the best moves for both
players right but there's a lot of ways
in which you can play even rook to c7 is
okay in this position
but that's not a natural move leaving
the plane made rook to e7 you want to
exchange the rook you don't feel like
going back to season rook to c7 wouldn't
have been on my radar wow i'd like your
rook e5
king e7
and getting uh the king activated again
well we're going to endorse this they're
going down on time he's down to his last
45 seconds we need to see a move from
shabbat of right now
whoa whoa whoa whoa
what 84
oh boy would i have been reluctant to
play that move because after bishop a2
i'm fearful that this knight
will
will have a permanent home and my
majority on the
queen side will never play
a4 what a committing move i would
i would be so reluctant especially so
close to the time control it's a 40th
move you don't generally want to change
the character of the position
with the upcoming 40th move still in
play well not just that but so many
endings could not like a bishop ending
could just be lost by the fact that you
don't have a passer or rook endings
could easily be you don't have you can't
create in a passer without sacrificing a
pawn but
quite quite quickly as well
the other
the other reason why i would be
reluctant to play a move like a4 it's
too easy for my opponent oh yeah
you know he's just gonna move his bishop
away and then it's sort of like
uh i still have the same problem i had a
moment ago what what was the real move i
wanted to play
shabba is going under a minute again
two more moves nope three more reaching
for the e5 rook
he's not certain
is fine i mean i feel i feel a little
more comfortable now i think i
understand what he wants
shabbat wants to go rook takes e5 and he
did knight takes e5 take on g4 all right
take on g4 and now the fact that this
rook is undefended i think he finally
wants to put
play for knight to e6
and knight f4 typically
oh
he is such a tactician always looking
for the tactical but what if you just
play king e7 just normal chess i know
that's instead of taking on g4 because
you are mentioning that b4 square very
important square but your knight is not
going back right now exactly because
knight d3 is met with bishop takes d5
yes there's no pin on the defense
take on g4 yes he's going for your line
yasser and he's attracted uh by the
flashiness of this
knight to e6 i think well i mean
breaking news yes dorsa
did win her game
bravo bravo uh again taking on g4 king
e7 i like knight e6 i understand why no
you can't play knight yes you can i mean
96 can i just point knight g6 check this
is the last move guys 40th move of time
control but i do let's get jennifer yes
yeah no i just want to mention i do
agree with that you said the moves that
blackboard making was making white
leading up yeah but like it was just
like you play a4 of course i'm going to
play bishop so you take my rook of
course i'm going to take back you take
my pawn of course i'm going to take that
so i think it did knight e8
knight e 8. um did was that move 40 by
the way yes
okay so the players have
made time control
uh gives us a moment that just catches
our breath i think i had a break from
the senior section
it's too stressful exactly exactly well
let's take a look at the ladies as uh we
have a remain a crucial remaining game
with talia
if i know my end game's right that that
that looks nice
it's an extra pawn it's passing
i'm happy absolutely we just we left it
around these parts queen g3 queen e2 was
played
rook g1
knight back to g6
and we've got a lot of moves kind of at
this moment you wouldn't be surprised by
a draw
no
rook queen takes
oh no
king g1 she gets to put a rook behind
yeah if the rock critical f8 a8 that's
kind of it yeah but there's a back rank
so usually whoops in these positions you
must have your rook behind her stuff she
totally knows her endings that is a
completely winning
rook and pawn ending
and talia will be tied with jennifer
one point behind sophie with a chance
to for destiny her own destiny yes she
could potentially win and make a playoff
and of course you play a4
and you push your pawn as far as you can
and then when white's king goes marching
over to deal with his or just bring the
other ones then you bring your king
up the board and you start capturing
pawns so this is actually remarkably
enough a simple
winning position for talia alice lee
rochelle
we um sophie had three chasers oh yes
and if i'm in sophie's position i'm
sitting there going okay guys let's see
three nice draws
no one rival wins no another rival wins
no
could rochelle win well alice lee says
not so fast
uh i don't want to lose she just played
the move h4 she did i'm
i was thinking that rochelle was going
to actually play g5 herself
not that this was a forced win or
anything like that but i had ideas of
maybe playing for g4 well maybe that's
why
was played to stop and i think that was
actually a very good move by alice
just
and
maybe on a good day she tries to sneak
her king that was my question what do
you want to do with your king
for the moment i'm just hoping that the
moment this rook moves
i get to play rook to c6
so you come down i go down you almost
want to have your pawn on f4 when your
rook lands on d2 so that you'll have f3
i don't think rochelle
is
close to winning this one i think that
uh alice could hold back one of sophie's
and guys i think we've seen a resulting
christopher use game okay
that is a victory for the leader of the
tournament and right now extending his
lead at the top with a game to go
beautiful well he came into the game
deep pardon me he came into the round
with a half point lead
over andrew how was andrew doing henry's
now the winning is not winning he's not
winning that's that's all i know he's
not he's probably not losing we're most
likely going to see a draw in that game
i don't think any other result there are
so many chances though there's no he's
not weird no previously i'm trying to
figure out where did it go wrong for
andrew because i the last thing i
remember is that uh andrew did gets this
a little bit of an advantage of material
imbalance um
he left it with the queen yeah he
captured and we thought
d5 was
the key moment right here
to uh
play
to stop this knight but he played rook
knight
a bit too passive allowing this knight
to get things start to trade off a
little a little too much exactly that's
exactly what happened and uh
no this is no problem for a wonder it's
it's kind of funny because earlier in
the tournament there was a game that
mishra was playing where it was queen
versus rook and a bishop yes and all the
pawns were on one side the current
position by the way is actually
a wonder
he's still got this past pawn and if
anybody's better
it's actually black because i don't
think black can ever lose these
positions uh can he win them
maybe probably
maybe one percent of the time one
percent of the time look at the game
lausch bordish versus uh
yeah sir and uh i won this uh ending
with uh rook and bishop nice uh against
the queen uh things were all on one side
um
queen to beast that one was played queen
to b7 yeah i'm not gonna really let that
pawn stay if i have the choice
exactly okay so if i go rook to d4
well rook to d4 i just take on b5 right
okay so we just trade off the pawn i was
wondering if you were going to defend
the pawn on g4 and allow me to play b5
b4 or
defend the pawn on g
or not
and then this is
by the way i think this is actually a
table base because the table basis kind
of
something happened on my screen that was
like
dang
okay uh again
a lot of victories in the junior
competition only three three wins i mean
to say one draw and a remaining game
dorset what else where would you like to
go well i think i'm ready to go back to
seniors
i'm ready let's go okay and
in fact
not the move
knight e6 which i thought
might be what
shabbo was playing for he said you know
what
the knight would actually be really well
placed on f6 why because on f6 it will
be attacking the pawn on d5 as well as
the pawn on g4
makes
perfectly logical sense that you would
want to do that as a
as
black
a moment ago i said you know one of the
things you wouldn't want to do is get
into a bishop ending yep because
this kind of thing could be really bad
news and it might
if white's king were on d4
the fact that black is about to play
king he failed means
white is completely lost uh which begs
the other question what about this check
and but now i don't have to take right
on d7 i can go k7 exactly precisely and
then your king could end up on the ideal
square the ideal blocking square bishop
takes d5 on the agenda
it moves like rook f4 um
my feeling is i'm looking at this
and
black is just absolutely fine and maybe
maybe better well the thing is it is why
that missed a big opportunity rook to f1
the last move the 41st move which is a
bit surprising it did not take uh um
longer to think about his options knight
to g6 would have created some serious
trouble
for black okay
g6 after king to f7 or king to g7 just
rook to e1 exactly
and uh guess who's showing up for dinner
exactly and you cannot go rook to d7 or
you can but d6 is coming and that's an
invite that's it
that i would love
um
but
actually knight g6
pardon me the knight g6 is
so
cool
i i actually
i was thinking obvious um
that's terrible a big miss here by uh
larry and uh let's jump to uh christian
who is
entertaining a guest guess who
christopher congratulations uh yesterday
a difficult game for you with the white
pieces but this is what champions do
they bounce back in fashion and you did
that today tell us about your feelings
right now as well as explain to us the
game today
i'm feeling definitely very relieved
especially after my rough game yesterday
i was feeling pretty nervous coming into
this game
absolutely you had a point and a half
lead going into yesterday's game
how did you deal with that loss
i i can't say i deal with it in the most
calm fashion i might have thrown a few
pillows and screamed a few bad words but
once i got that out of my system it was
just about focusing on the next game
absolutely and that you did you came up
with this uh very interesting
preparation g4
and then yet he came back with this idea
of g5 were you surprised by his
knowledge
i was a bit surprised like i did kind of
remember the computer flashing g5 at me
when i was preparing but i was like you
didn't know way too seriously i just
moved
when he came on the board i was quite
scared for a moment like what kind of
preparation is he up to and he continued
you took on g5 and he continued with
castle immediately played
were you at all worried that this
position might uh be difficult for you
to play over the board yeah i was
definitely a bit worried
and let's keep going
now i want to take you to this moment
after knight takes g4
what were the candidate moves that
flashed through your eyes right now you
played queen 24 but
what were the canvas move that you were
discussing
i think i also considered c takes d5 and
knight takes e4 maybe
and did you consider knight to d4 at all
not that much
i think i saw the knight g5
knight g5
and what if you just take on e4
maybe queen to a4 right now
yeah i think i missed this queen to a4
move
quite interesting knight to d4 was an
opportunity the computer was actually
saying plus five
after knight knight d4
wow
just completely crushing and you played
this move queen to a4 and he found queen
to be for a good move but after that it
seemed like you took over in the end
game you started outplaying him with
every single move
did you feel that way as well
i'm not exactly sure at some point when
i felt like when i did this pawn
sacrifice i didn't actually think it was
that queer
and what were you worried about after f3
and take on f3 bishop takes f3
what were you worried about
i actually thought rick g6 was the best
move
we i just didn't feel like i was playing
it in the best way because i had to sack
a pawn
we were considering rook to d2 right now
as well
the idea
i thought just bishop g freedom now at
knight d3
and what was uh what was your
calculation here
i actually i honestly didn't look into
this variation that much there was a
funny line right now if you take on c6
obviously you don't have to take on c6
but if you do knight f2 king g1
now you have this knight h3 followed by
rook h2
and and the checkmate comes on the board
it's a very
visual checkmate
if you want to put it that way
so let's go back he decided to play uh
to defend passively this position with
rook to g6
and after that it was
all christopher you in
this game
christopher you
did you keep an eye on the game of
wonder versus uh
versus andrew
yeah i kept a bit of an eye on it
i'm kind of interested to see what the
position is now let's take a look at
that maybe we can bring it
on yasser's board or that one what do
you think about this end game does the
wonder have any chances whatsoever
i do think he has a little bit of a
chance and it's kind of nice to see that
his position is very safe i don't think
he has much chance of losing this
absolutely and i think he will uh try to
nurse this slight advantage for quite a
while from now on christopher
congratulations you're moving one step
closer to a big title for you what would
that championship title mean for you
it would definitely mean quite a lot
i'm i'm definitely looking
forward to it but
tomorrow i'm just gonna play like any
other game and just focus on making good
moves
absolutely i think that's the best
strategy congratulations once again
christopher we'll see you tomorrow thank
you our congratulations as well
christopher and good luck tomorrow the
championship run if he wins
uh he's got nice prize money
and he's got nice scholarship money of
ten thousand dollars
but then he's going to have a very nice
challenge of playing in the u.s
championship good friends have
playing faviano lanier dominguez uh uh
get your prep is what i would say to uh
chris i was also thinking if
uh andrew hall
drew's doesn't win this which is
probably not going to happen exactly
yeah let's say they draw right then
carissa will play christopher yes but
christopher already has secured the um a
one-point lead
yes
but if andrew loses
then he's the champion yeah he will have
secured the championship
which is even better and there's still a
chance that maybe
he's not going to hold this
uh oh i don't think no i'm sure
i'm like yeah he's i'm sure he's not
repeating uh there's only one player
that can play for a win here it's a
wonder exactly
very uh
very nice very interesting judgment by a
wonder
liang to sacrifice his queen
with this variation with queen f6
because that was by no means necessary
and maybe he was slightly worse at the
moment that white could play d5 andrew
missed his chance and andrew is
struggling now
suddenly uh to hold the draw well we'll
keep that in mind and again uh the
seniors i'm very i'm again i'm very
curious what larry
larry did not play the move knight g6 by
the way that's just my analysis board oh
well maybe he did
maybe a little too late actually
exactly maybe too late he first played
the rook to f1 check
and
now he played knight to g6 i guess he's
got well he's still got to play rookie
one doesn't he but his i
i have this awful feeling that he missed
a golden opportunity
you have to play king d8
because king f7 would be
egregiously
excuse me an opportunity or is he worse
right now well i'm thinking
well i just was looking at this crazy
line nice cheap nice cheapos knight to
h8 it looks a little funny if you try to
play rook to d7 to stop me that's what
i'm trying to play here but if you take
my pawn
i take your bishop
i agree
g4 is hanging
this is not the way i want to play as
white by the way
uh but uh because i'm a little bit
worried that i'm the one everything is
falling right
no no this is exactly the way you want
to play this game oh you do it's pretty
much the only way to play this game oh
for larry for larry right now if he
doesn't find this rook to e1 followed by
nightweight h8 then he's in big trouble
oh really okay big big trouble
and if he finds it probably he has good
chances of holding but it is still
shabalov who is putting on the pressure
exactly so if we go back to the moment
where where
instead of that move rook f1 which was
bad
had he played knight g6 immediately what
was the computer's assessment of larry's
position uh decisive advantage oh this
site so he went from a winning position
to a slightly worse position yes
with his 41st move in this fourth fifth
hour of play i just missed his moment in
fact this this is what the engine is
recommending knight to g6 king to f7
and just give up the piece
how rook to e1 bishop takes d5
and just allow just allow rook to e7 so
bishop takes d5 take on this five rook
to e7 followed by rook takes e8 and just
try to survive this one but
it's not
first of all it's not an easy decision
to just simply give up the piece like
this and then not an easy calculation
and pretty much survival situation right
now because
i can go rook to e5 take on b5 i have so
many ways in which i can play this
position with the white pieces go for
exactly the h pawn as well that's a
strategy that i could employ right this
one is only why does playing for a
victory two results yeah results
so uh that that was uh
um maybe he says
the nerves got to him got to harry
and
he did play rook f1 and helped his
opponent and we think that after rook e1
king d8 shabbos for choice i want to do
quickly
vladimir has been nursing an extra pawn
for some time he sure doesn't feel
any closer uh to uh making a
breakthrough against joel benjamin that
game looks like it's heading to a draw
by the way
vladimir comes into the round a half a
point behind
if larry were to draw and this game's a
draw
how many people would that's
five people five people at the top like
what
five a live jam at the time four
larry would need to lose though yes
that's what yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
if larry loses and there is a
possibility that he might
fall in that position i mean he is
slightly worse right now he has played
rookie one king d8 for shabba is
definitely fourth
a five-way tie for first 508 tie for
first gold last round
wait a minute dorsal
help me out here
oh boy we started with 10 people
a 10 round
round robin you put up a playoffs where
i asked you what happens if three or
four players
tied for fours what if there's five
never mind two players i i didn't ask
about five tell me what we're going to
do with five i mean three or four i
wrote coin time coin
i i like the roulette wheel uh what say
you christian no absolutely five points
because it is
oh my goodness we're actually being told
that
in case of that
you have some mathematical formula where
where players get eliminated
uh and then you have the playoffs
there's always going to be a playoff but
no coin top but you're not gonna get a
six or seven or something like that
you're gonna eliminate players based on
head-to-heads uh lower-rated uh
strength of schedules all kinds of weird
stuff
and i'm sure we're going to have i think
arbiters actually just say he's my
favorite i'm going to go
i'm sorry i mean you have three arbiters
right you have three arbiters each one
of them pick their own favorite
that makes the most sense what about the
commentators right
nobody
i know isn't that the worst feeling in
the world i mean everybody remembers
who was the champion
they never say oh that was where you
guys were commentating
none of that just doesn't happen
oh boy oh boy terrible
um
wow uh where would you like to go dorsa
we were just seeing this game of larry
christensen and we're watching
larry
ooh he didn't play night h8 he did not
we're watching larry spoil
his things and he realizes
look at him he's now really digging in
deep uh and he's
as focused as he can be but he realizes
he's he's blown his advantage
a little bit yeah no no he hasn't blown
his advantage she's lost right now oh
wow
lost that's cruel why knight takes g4
gift me the pawn gift me the pawn
or zero compensation knight to f5 rook
f6
well when you put it like that
jeez
i don't know dorset we're watching uh a
big big turn around in this senior
championships um where do i want to go i
want to go on break there we go that's
it that's exactly what we wanted to hear
and we're going to see you on the other
side of the break
[Music]
welcome to the chess capital of the
united states
the st louis chess campus in the heart
of the vibrant central west end has
established itself as a premier global
destination for chess and is comprised
of two unique non-profit institutions
the chess club and scholastic center of
st louis is recognized as the top chess
facility in the world and plays host to
all major tournaments including the u.s
chess championships and the sinkfield
cup one of the strongest chess
tournaments globally
tournaments are broadcast online to more
than 150 countries led by an expert
commentary team of grand masters
the chess club is an educational
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess with a specific focus on
bringing the benefits of chess to
children throughout the st louis area
research shows children who play chess
exhibit improved analytical skills and
increased confidence the chess club is
highly engaged with the local community
bringing scholastic chess programs to
more than 100 schools providing hundreds
of classes each week
directly across the street from the
chess club is the world chess hall of
fame this one-of-a-kind cultural
institution invites visitors to
experience chess in imaginative ways and
is home to the u.s and world chess halls
of faith
cutting edge exhibitions feature rare
historic chess artifacts paired with
world-class art innovative programming
explores the intersection of chess art
and culture
visitors can enjoy interactive programs
designed around the exhibitions and
monthly music in the galleries
the world chess hall of fame is nothing
you expect and everything you love three
different galleries and a premier gift
shop highlight the culture history and
creativity behind the game come visit
play chess leave enriched to learn more
about the st louis chess campus visit
stlchestcampus.org
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to our
live coverage of the 2022
u.s girls u.s juniors and u.s seniors
championships
and we have a result as we're coming on
on the air
yeah
yeah alice and rochelle ellis lee and
rochelle will have made a draw rochelle
in order to keep pace needed a win so a
little bit of a disappointment but i
think it was actually a very well played
game so
no harm no foul
wonderfully done that means that
rochelle is out of contention for the
title
exactly
and
who is still fighting as well as jenny
for you who actually won her game how's
that game going the one the italian game
well let's take a look at that one and
see we had that end game that we thought
it's just easy win right yeah exactly
behind the pawn and i don't think
anything has changed i'm just going to
use
this king go to f5 where are you going
to go now exactly i still don't see and
at some point i will give you the a pawn
if you try to keep the king where it is
right now so for example if you go king
to d5 try to keep opposition and say
that you're not going to allow my king
to go to the queen side then i can give
you a check
move the king backwards and then
give you the a part but at the same time
grab both of these pawns and your king
is very far away you're not going to be
able to defend this one so this is
another way to potentially get the
victory and uh create the separation
between these two players right now king
to e6 is on the board we believe this
one is going to go talia's way exactly
and again before the game uh before the
result between alice and michelle uh
there was two wins out of two
the number of decisive games in all
three events has just been for me
i've been calling events for a decade
longer astonishing i'm just not used to
seeing this many victories dorset i mean
uh and it it just is that the players
have come to saint louis
shoes
one of the things i must say that it's
the atmosphere here as well you come
into a really beautiful club you sit
down you've got these nice pieces you've
got these nice sets you've got these
arbiters who are making sure that every
need that you may have is being taken
care of and you feel like
you know what i really want to do my
absolute best and
that's what is we're witnessing
the the club is bringing out the best
and the players yes it's quite quite
beautiful it's wonderful yes guys
okay i guess christian has some news
check the game of larry christiansen
big game that we have right now on our
hands larry versus chabalov
do you want me to give you the
assessment right now
it's minus five i'm not even going to uh
wow you're telling me yes it's minus
five
wow
game over
with the best moves for black and the
best moves are not that difficult well
the problem is this knight on g8 is just
dead right that it's dead but is that
dude by the knight i can't even do d6
okay that hurts d6 will give you a check
made in one move yeah so even something
like rook c5 if you
if you're worried about bishop takes d5
oops that's
lights out
to c3 or rook to c3 broke the c3 what do
you do next
rook to c3 i am assuming i've
i'm going to close my eyes a6
bishop a6 sure why not
this is not the lazy man's variation but
i do understand that my bishop
is crying
just got bad so fast
this is not looking good guys no well
now i just simply have
look to see
that's that might be a problem actually
actually just my king
you crafted may be a problem you
craftily put your bishop uh on a6
i did
i was completely unawares that my king
so right to g3 followed by
bishop to e2 oh god this is like e2 or
bishop to d3 yeah either one e3 maybe
you have knight f6
i
i think it's gone yeah it's gone i think
it's just larry
wow what a
extraordinary turnover of events guys
wow and it was so
it was
i want to say i mean nothing ever in
these tournaments it's like nothing ever
is simple but in this case i have to
absolutely say this was simple and
straightforward it was a check
king f7
rook e1 nothing could be
more obvious than
dropping the rook in on the e7 square
which is what you wanted
when you opened up the e-file ages ago
big deal vladimir kopi and has gotten
the best he could ever
hope for
and it still doesn't feel like it's
enough
uh christian that still feels like
uh joel is managing to draw that game i
wanted to he should be able to but at
the same time doesn't that feel like
maybe he's getting closer
yes breakthrough right now i just feel
like e5 e4 might come on the board at
some point maybe e5 f4 as well i just
need to get the king somehow
i mean it might be time that we have to
re
release our king but the problem is once
you do that i actually think i just
exchanged the rooks really that endgame
i think is a very easy draw
because you'll be able to play king and
exchange one pawn as well yes i think so
okay
and maybe i don't even have to exchange
the pawn i just leave the king on e2 and
that's it
well he's not leaving his king anywhere
joel is
taking a walk
uh with the move king c4 wanted to turn
our attention to the junior games
because it was that a wonder game that
really hadn't junior girls oh sorry
junior junior junior juniors
uh and again a lot of decisive games
here andrew uh versus a wonder this is
let's just play coin h7 on that
right remember that wonderful game
lasted forever in the world championship
oh
this does not look like a very happy
andrew here
he is seems to be suffering remember the
world championship um dubai
uh game six that lasted forever and ever
where magnus with his king and he just
very carefully guided his pawns up the
board well
uh wonder is is taking a page out of his
magnus carlson book and somehow he's
creeping up the board whether it's
serious or not
i kind of just want to play queen f7
right now queen f7 i want to throw in a
cheapo
well i
i can very well understand why you would
uh want to checkmate me um
okay i'll throw in a cheapo
wait
i can't do it
why can't i take
i can't make the audio i can't do it i
can't do it the computer won't let me
make an illegal move we have a guest in
studio
we are indeed with jennifer you jennifer
yesterday you came out to the show and
you said i'm going to take it one game
at a time and this is exactly what
you're doing how do you feel right now
and what do you how do you feel about
the round as a whole um
i think this game went pretty smoothly
uh i probably didn't play the opening
that accurately um
i had like i assumed she prepped
something and i
like kind of didn't remember my line so
much and also just wanted to get her a
little bit out of prep so i i think i'm
probably gonna play the most accurately
but um at some point i think i started
outplaying her and i don't think it was
any big problems so it's pretty good and
what about sophie's game like what was
your take on that i saw it and then at
first i thought she it was like some i
didn't know she was down by a piece her
opponent so i thought um she was like
down by a pawn at first i was like okay
maybe some just some opening thing that
i don't know about and i realized she
was down by a piece i was like okay well
that happens i guess
but you're still maintaining striking
distance to sofiane she does have a very
difficult match against talia tomorrow
how do you feel about your chances are
you thinking about that game between
these two ladies at all or once again
you're just focusing on your own game
um well
i don't really like to leave it up to
other people decide how my tournament
goes so
um i mean i guess it's really out of my
hand so it doesn't matter i'm
obviously trying my best to win tomorrow
but it's not like i'm not
gonna count on
um that game changing my tournament and
let's take a look at today's game as
well now just uh simply tell us where do
you feel like you're taking over and
where do you feel like you're building
up a decisive advantage
yeah so after um e5
uh knight d3 e5
um yeah around this point it's she's
starting to go backwards and then i have
enough initiative to um start pushing on
the king side and i think this is just
much better now
and she didn't seem to be able to build
anything on the queen side yeah i think
like my work on b3 is actually pretty
strong because it prevents um
black from really doing anything and uh
the bishops and queen are defending my
position yeah that's what we thought as
well and uh it seemed like the
conversion went quite smoothly for you
jennifer congratulations we'll let you
go we'll let you get some rest and get
ready for uh tomorrow match a big one
congratulations
jennifer and good luck
tomorrow in our championship saturday
edition
of these uh u.s championships do you
think we'll actually have playoffs
pardon do you think we'll actually have
playoffs pardon me
i'm gonna ask
uh we have had some very long broadcasts
haven't we guys we're gonna have five
players tied for the top in the senior
section you were i think we will have
playoffs i will not i'll call it is it
too late i think we will have fun you're
not allowed to say that and five players
playing in one
of the three events it's incredible it's
incredible what's happening uh and
it was a turn on a dime in that game
between larry christensen and shabalov
and right now it seems like shibalo is
just having full control of his destiny
we are going to have uh some stats for
you tomorrow because i'm more than
curious
whoa guys guys what's happening where's
my night if talia and uh
what what is happening here guys wait is
well
uh you're gonna lose the h5 pawn yeah
that's a yes take bishop
f3 but is this a winning bishop ending i
i
i'm stunned then there's a knight there
what oh there's a knight on h6
oh sorry
i assumed it was a bond i feel like i
feel like uh jennifer who came in and
said oh he's a she's a pawn out that
must be something
that's a nice not a piece okay it's a
completely different story
that is funny that bird's eye view uh
uh
it's surprised us all no it must be
winning i mean it's an extra piece
it's full stop
nothing to be nothing to discuss
bishop f3 you take the pawn and
you're a happy camper
as larry will
tumble down the ranks and for
shabala winning with the black pieces
what a dream
wow
more or less on demand
is what he did
here today
oh i think we're going to see our bishop
and knight versus king we're going to
see the mate
you think so i think so i think we're
going to go straight into that and
shabbat will have to show his uh prowess
i've actually never seen that live
happening i've always seen the after
games
you know i'm trying to think in my whole
tournament practice i i've had just
about every endings you can imagine
queen versus rook
rook and bishop versus
rook many many times maybe as many seven
times i've never had bishop and knight
versus never i've never had it
i
i really haven't even had two nights
uh versus a pawn either
no
it's crazy yeah me too it's like
certain end games that we learned
and it never happened
and king
yeah king of the hill king of the hell
right
he would win
king e4 that would be a winning move
king of the hill
so how would
how would you go about
winning this or at least explaining it
to your students
how would you
start for black uh christians well i i
think you have to keep uh the king close
to the queen side first of all
um because if you don't then the a pawn
might be running away this looks like a
really good starting move yes because
now the bishop cannot be traded for no
you have to drop back with the bishop
and that's going to allow me to give the
check bishop to uh c6
and then you have to declare where you
want to put your king right right and
maybe i don't even start with bishop
exactly came to d6 not allow the king to
go to e5 right and now bishop to c6 is
coming on the board after that kings to
c5 pick up the a pawn
and then move on start pushing the g
pawn with the help of your king and at
some point force the bishop to be traded
for the g pawn and then convert with
bishop and knight versus king
makes sense uh that looks like and i
think is is pretty sure of every certain
of what he has to do right i mean the
way he's still thinking exactly that is
the look of a very very confident man
almost as if
you know i studied this position
probably you can even start going g4
right
g4 g3 and g2 and because
or you can start with the knight yeah
this looks like
again you're already
knight e3 check could be a potential
fork so you have to play
what larry did which was king back and
you were mentioning king c5 to b4
as one way his his uh dealing with the
position in a much cleaner uh way than
than than we are i have to say
um speak for yourself what is it why did
you say we
we had this all oh oh
we got this
and let's not forget dennis is in the
truck cheering on his pig that is
shibalov
i thought he's dead in the water a
couple of games ago and shibalov is
coming back yesterday i mean
what a save against melinsky he was
at move
15 good white pieces actually it was
check made in a few moves and so was he
ever dead but we are about to see bishop
e4 check king d4 93 and you're right we
may be getting the knight in bishop
combination oh we ending we will for
sure
see that i don't think larry is going to
to uh
resign right
once you force
the bishop to be given up for the g pawn
might want to see
shibala's technique by the way i know
that there's a software tool
that coaches are using
where they can say okay
you play against the computer engine
and you've got 30 seconds
to
show me the mate do you use those tools
for your
uh students uh
i have no idea what you're doing yeah
exactly i'm trying to get trying to give
you a winning grade you know like if you
know what is coming up if you know what
the challenges are going to be when you
coach all types of questions right
i don't know what softwares you're
talking about yes
really
there it might be on leachat they have
some engines they're training tools uh
that they use
and i like this move bishop b5 too
sounds like a gimmick to me yeah ah
sounds like a gimmick to me no no okay
now bishop a6 followed by king to d4 if
you don't go kings to c5 i think that
will actually force bishop is hanging
hanging on d1 there's no reason to take
it right now right
just uh go
bishop a6 hide in the bishop dd4 i just
want to bring your attention to the
please andrew and a wonder game
because there is a very
lovely ah there we go i just wanted to
bring up the
pawn and game that you're about to enter
pawn ending well
king takes g2 yes that's a draw yeah
yeah
just two moves ago it was quite
interesting that the queen
and the king and queen were just like
whoop all the way in the
all the way
right exactly
right but yeah this is um this is a draw
yeah and they accepted the draw
wonderful so that kind of concludes our
round eight for the junior section right
what was interesting is just before the
end
a wonder had laid a wonderful trap i see
he played this move rook g2 check and
said please take my rook and in this
case this is actually a losing yeah
king upon endgame it may look identical
to the final position it's not after the
move king g4 king f2
king f4 white is actually winning in the
game position
oops excuse me
in the game position
they got
this
where it was black to move so you gotta
push that pawn right and then i step in
front of it and it's a draw
wow okay so
two draws oh this is over the big game
of our section larry resigned after
bishop a6 what
a
he's not happy no what a phoenix he is
not happy
alex shivalov he has
come out of nowhere if you will
was in the crypt
and
now he's in contention
holy smokes
[Laughter]
and it all started this this whole
comeback started with that game against
kaidanov
with the black pieces when he was
completely lost right
and yet he managed to swindle his
opponent and after that just started
this resurgence within the rankings he
won that one i think he won another one
and now a third one in a row is that no
i think he drew against malinitsky but
still yes
yesterday or in the last four rounds
that's just a ridiculous
score um and yes shabalov is just coming
back now we have a five-way tie
at the top with a lot of these players
actually playing against each other
right tomorrow so so we can fantastic
if everybody draws we can't exactly
you were not allowed to say how many
playoffs we
because it's a commentator's curse
the moment a commentator says
and we have a clear champion no we don't
we have a six-weight tiger first
wow
oh wait
joe benjamin is still in fighting
yes no no the junior section this means
that
christopher you
is our champion uh
isn't the player no he's not no he's not
he's guaranteed a playoff
because he's a point ahead only one yes
only one point yes so that's that
at least we might have another play-off
too he has a draw odds
why are you so happy
we're gonna be
is your game here
i guess what is andrew hong playing
tomorrow
oh um do you expect me to know that
he would
say
he will be playing with the black pieces
so i i have to say christopher you he's
playing a struggling player with the
black piece that's karissa nevertheless
never count carissa out she can produce
incredible games and incredible
surprises and she's beat countless of uh
grand masters in her young career so
karissa is by no means any pushover and
she has absolutely nothing to lose
dorothy on the other hand it seems like
andrew hong is going to be playing
espinosa yeah darsa has all the answers
for you go ahead dorset
they're
andrew hong will be playing espinoza
with black yes okay
pedro is white yep
and chris is white versus christopher
you
and both karissa and petra seems to be
having a
rough tournament oh rough rough is a
good way of describing it christopher
with a one point lead heading into
championship saturday that's all
tomorrow andrew a point behind david
brodsky also coming out of nowhere look
at this right he's in a tie for third a
point behind andrew i just wanted to
mention that the good news would be even
if you get a tie break it won't be a
tight break for a three-way timer that's
true
the max we can do here is a two-way deal
and more results dorsal let's go for it
yes sir
well justine wang and chris
did draw their game
and
so many results curious to see who's
next yes jennifer you did win her game
against gracie giving her a really
wonderful six out of eight you would
think with such a score you're fighting
for first yeah kind of but you're whole
point behind
wow but comparing that to our senior
section which everybody's like at five
points exactly quite interesting and
christopher you did win his game against
mishra
uh to score six and a half and uh
you guarantee himself at least a playoff
that's what we want to say
more and more more results coming
through rochelle and alice did draw
their games which puts rochelle out of
any fight for the first place exactly
let's see
and finally oh this one hurts the big
result that really hurts larry goes down
with the white pieces to chop olive
which now
means it's a massive tiger
tie break maybe more except there is
still one game going on right vladimir
now vladimir if he draws he's going to
be in that tie
however if he wins however unlikely that
might be
he would be our tournament leader going
into the last round and he is nursing
let's face it an extra pawn christian
thinks
black's chances of winning are
slim to none but nonetheless whenever
you're upon up and you're in an ending
you want to press your luck as best you
can bishop e3 joel uh
played this very quickly i just want to
touch up on tomorrow's preparing for our
seniors so uh vladimir maricopian is
playing the uh nick who is not having a
good tournament exactly uh igor novikov
is playing against joe benjamin right
shabalov will be playing maxime
now that is a game that was likely to
decide first go on and then go ravish
versus larry another game likely to
decide first and cardinal versus the
other igor
all right um wow we've got some great
matches a lot of
head-to-heads and
we'll just have to see
yeah
yeah it was just
i wanted to i'm looking at the game
between joel benjamin and
vladimirokobian and
i want kristen to jump in on this exact
position right here because there was
some
some
funny tactics uh but before we do this
i'm happy i'm not going to jump in but
we can ask uh our guest
alexander chabalov after an incredible
victory congratulations uh alex
incredible performance with the black
pieces against
a terrific opponent all right
thank you so much all after
last night i think everything felt good
so
uh
yeah it's unbelievable uh scenario in uh
our championship right now i mean
larry played the
hell of a tournament you know there was
a and uh everything looked like
he's going to
be unstoppable on the way to the title
but uh well
you know uh
we all planted to the end and uh
and
uh well
what about the game itself right so uh
no clearly uh i was preparing for lars
nimto and uh
after
quite a
quite a
long thing he decided not to go for it
and played something
safe
i guess save but then he allowed this
uh hanging pawn structure which was a
little bit surprising so he played safe
then but i guess
larry also wanted to
clinch today if you could have uh
but surprisingly this game
really reminded me our our first meeting
with larry which was a
u.s championship in 1993.
i was uh
almost the same structure there was like
uh isolated pawn i was on the black side
uh
at some point
i just
overstepped you know the
limits and
i won
and it did seem like right now he was
building up some pressure right whenever
you move the knife from c6 it jumps
to e5
how did you assess the position yes and
no i i wasn't too worried i mean so you
were happy with the impact it's a
wide standing pretty active but uh yeah
that's exactly what i wanted to gives
you some chances as well to strike
potentially
uh
so
but of course eventually
he clearly overplayed me it's uh
so here was knight on h3 i thought i
could
couldn't possibly be worse and you
weren't actually knight h3 or better
after g5 yeah but then i really didn't
like my position i think rookie 5 was
very strong
knight g7 and bishop c2
so there's no time i can
get this rook off i think here there was
a ridiculous
maneuver proposed by the engine bishop
takes b3 takes and then rook to c5
to get rid of the rook on on on e5 and
so this is the way to reduce the
pressure okay
and if you go rook to e3 then look to d5
and i shouldn't have too many problems
here okay yeah yeah that looks good
but it's not human to
play just like that
so yeah here larry clearly i grabbed the
initiative and but uh
i think 23 he played like
i mean anything that does not allow me
to trade queens i mean
it would be dangerous
but this one stepped right into actually
i wasn't sure about taking on uh d5 for
white uh
probably at this point from practical
point of view taking on b5 was better
at least that's what i thought taking on
b5 and if you do take if you do go uh
with the same queen two currency six no
i think it's the same position only
instead of like a weak pawn on d5
he got two on one and a queen side so
that that's what i but
how does he get on one so a4 yeah but
then i can go a6 right
uh a6 i thought a little dangerous rook
takes b6 takes
yeah so i it wasn't that easy to get rid
of those two ones on the queensland and
he took on d5 allowed me to trade coins
the worst was over but uh
i think somewhere around here larry
still relied a lot on tactics instead of
uh trying to
like
make a draw i think what him oh so this
was the critical moment okay after 98 is
a mistake 98.99 g6 would have been quite
problematic for you did you spot this
move
oh what
do you want
no no no no no
okay uh
knight g6
uh knight g6 right okay yes
uh
no frankly i had 40 40 seconds on my
clock when i played 98 uh no i did not
look at it uh oh wow
but this was the 41st move so he had
some time to spend and try to figure
things out oh really yes did he play did
he make an immediate move
to f1 he
he didn't wait until he his time expired
yeah for some reason he played it
extremely fast rook f1 probably missed
some time i i'm pretty sure what he
missed he missed that rook f1 knight f6
uh
knight f6 knight d7
uh
king e7
knight takes f6
takes and d6 i'm sure he was hoping for
that yeah just forgot about that bishop
on a2 is also hanging yesterday takes d6
but i i thought that's actually his best
chance to
to make a draw if he wanted to so yeah
picks up the bishop i'll pick up his
bishop he takes b5 takes a3
uh
uh probably f3 i thought just i think
you want to go to
i think you want to go to e4 right so f3
yeah three and e4
uh yeah i thought this this was
promising
like uh i wasn't sure if it's easy draw
but uh
it feels like it was king like that king
gets activated
and uh
so but
for some reason
yeah but he played knight g6 extremely
fast
oh no no no no no no rook f1 he played
okay and then nighttime
which is another mistake i think and
right now it just felt like things are
going from bad to worse for him yes
and the last moment
it seems like it was here
night weight jade
yes to maintain the balance in the
position oh knight h knight h8
oh whoa
and now we get
the end game after bishop takes d5
taking d5 knight f6 h6 okay and at the
end he takes on hc you're still better
with black right now but good chances
for him to be to equalize oh that's true
well his night is slightly worse but uh
yeah definitely i i see some chances but
still you're better with black right now
okay
oh wow so we both were missing a lot
let's get back to the game uh okay
and
when did you feel and
also when did you feel the energy shift
in this game in this end game right now
when did you feel the energy shift oh i
i thought when he played knight g6 that
he already missed that but apparently it
was not yet but
uh yeah surprisingly white king is
extremely bad you know they made in that
so
that's it
yeah alex congratulations i mean after
that it was a pretty smooth uh
conversion congratulations you're tied
at the top
right now and now hopefully joel will
not lose this
probably not but
it's still in play yeah we're
crossing our fingers that he's not and
then it's
amazing uh day tomorrow
tomorrow against uh max uh what is your
usual experience with uh uh no obviously
i didn't play max
too many times well our like active
phases were a little bit uh
you know
not not synchronized yeah when he was
active i i was not that strong yet and
and then later but we played couple of
times and
i believe the last uh meeting uh i beat
him in a
uh senior championship at 19 here
so but it was a different color
and max is playing unbelievable i think
he's a he like right now there's a
player with the most energy
i see how he tries to win every single
game i mean it's very impressive so
i'm not going to take it lightly and
we'll see how it goes definitely a lot
of energy on your side as well we'll let
you go back get some preparation going
and we'll see you tomorrow thank you not
quite so fast not quite so fast first of
all two quick questions for you alex
first of all congratulations well done
have you ever played bishop at night
versus king
uh in a tournament game
you mean two pieces versus king oh ben
fungal
made me
do it twice
one wise guy you know yeah no i mean
after i did it once i would think
you know it's not going to try it again
but no i mean
so i
he's responsible for me you know knowing
this hung game
wonderful so you played it twice but
against the same guy i think he has the
same guy and i think it was within a
year so
okay second quick question for you you
just played around shabbat this is crazy
you just played around
five great legendary play
five great legendary
games ten players
four decisive results
is that a lot
yeah
but but you guys have been doing it more
or less since round four that you guys
have really been uh killing one another
why the pummelings what's going on
uh
i well
it's very easy explanation there's a i
think the guys who are not playing that
much uh set in the tone uh max and
dmitry
uh have an unbelievable tournament and
uh
even igor melninsky who's uh
on bottom of the
tournament table i mean plays amazing
chess okay so
um people who didn't play for a long
time just wanted to play that's my
explanation
very good well we'll let you go now and
good luck tomorrow uh in the
championship round yep thanks yasir
thanks dorsar thank you thanks
wonderful and dorsey you've been looking
at the game of tell you i see that and i
want her to win you want her to win i
need something
here we go but if she wins she gets
closer to tybrick wait wait wait wait
wait wait what are you using myself
exactly exactly see i i talia was my you
know teammate that was her captain
everything and so i i want her to win
but i really don't want to play
now she has made tremendous progress
since we left it because it's all about
the fact that white uh rujan jens rook
is tethered to this pond so
white is bringing her king over to the
queen side so that she can release her
rook defend and blockade with the pawn
and we've just seen the move king b1 on
the board so that's a clear indication
that white is ready to go
rook to e3 now in these positions
how should talia
respond to this i just want to play king
before king b4 and i'm fine with
drinking three rook e3 and how would it
go you would you would you like your
rook here as a defensive measure or
would you like your rook
active like maybe coming down over here
well i was thinking about the rocket
fight id oh
well she just played a different
oh look at that tricky move she just
played came to v-u-l that's a lovely
chief oh king to v1
talia said you know what i want to
activate my rook right away
so that i can come down check check and
this was what christian was saying
oftentimes you get rid of the a pawn for
white stewpot
and it's lovely
check
uh it's almost like a savarde study
where you've got the back rank mate and
the rook is hanging this day what study
made by cervantes that sounds about
right yes
made by cervantes yes
the it's s double a v a rd that was a
very very famous study
from the 1800s and what happened was the
columnist
put you know how to draw
and he showed the draw and everybody was
happy but the savarte
he may have been a priest i'm not sure
said no
you're wrong
there's a cook
the player wins the game
and the columnist was shocked and he was
so delighted and that was how it became
the savart study it's really really
really a beautiful one but this is nice
but guys yes there is one very early
story today and that was the story of
sophie maurice suzuki just getting a uh
killing advantage after the opening and
uh our producers actually came up with a
very beautiful graphic as you can see as
we move along uh throughout this game at
move seven something happens right after
move seven and you can see going the
graphic from around 20 winning chances
all the way to 90 plus percent winning
chances
that knight fd7 move was such a bad
decision by uh vela today and i have to
say that was just simply a gift for
maurice suzuki
best 58 minutes of our day i have to say
well indeed uh that was just a gift
and we saw dimitri gurvich getting a
nice gift as there was an oversight uh
the move rook e8 has paid dividends uh
for talia
rookie eight uh ruey again went
king c2 but then came your king b4 and
look at this rookie two check
on the board and talia is about to clip
her second pawn and that's then she will
really be cruising towards victory no
question about it uh with
with uh that second pawn in her pocket
rook takes
h2 we're expecting now
so
with this victory and it's all but
certain
talia is going to go into the last round
game trailing sofia by a whole point but
with destiny
in front of her can she win with the
white pieces and for sophia by the way i
mean we are taught we've been talking
about her when she went on the 6-0 run
and there's the handshake
6-0 run it's remarkable that sophia
hasn't put the the tournament in her
pocket she's got seven
out of eight a tremendous score i mean
that wins championship seven out of nine
is a terrific score
it could be a a three-way tie like
that's crazy i just realized that um
none of our seniors would make it to
seven no
that's why i'm saying
it's a remarkably good score and also
for christopher you who also has a
remarkably uh great score no guarantee
for christopher either
and uh the seniors seem to be up for
grabs there is one game left for the
ladies i apologize to ellen and zoey
so total of two games left yeah i like
it let's just watch like we haven't seen
ellen and zoey for some time but it just
looks like
and that's it
that's uh ellen is
losing this game most definitely i
expect but this game to be wrapped up
very shortly yeah because d5 falls g5
falls then just trade on g3 and go upon
cruising exactly rook to e
three i would still just eat on d5 you
eat e4 g5 whatever you do or pre-move
rook takes g3 this is all free moves i
mean there is one game that has any
importance towards the standings that's
a copious game we have to move on to
that one
because he's still fighting say half
italian uh
i i i think ellen was about to resign
but okay
oh
wonderful
okay so we have only one game
we made it
exactly
and
joel versus vladimir and the bishops got
traded
no oh boy i mean every time i'm thinking
let's just call this guy it gave uh it
just feels like i don't know but joel
allows some
type of
improvement by by white by black the
king is pretty cut on the background
right even if the king was on f6 it
would be a draw
but uh this three versus two with the
king on f6
is
well i think improvement is an
overstatement
over an
oh absolutely i think this is getting
closer and closer to
a position that joel is just comfortable
holding and i think without the bishops
three versus two not only that but the
only way to make any progress at some
point will be to go for rook d5 rook d7
right which is exactly where he's
heading right now and then i just hide
the king to e2 and then you will have to
spend a lot of time to get
your e5 and then f4 and that's going to
change the structure but he knows he
knows this end game he studied this end
game with the bishops on the board
you're making it sound like it's easy
peasy
and it's not it's not this is exactly
how you lose it
he
he had much much much easier
drawing methods with a bishop no no
easily i was trying to
i would you
we had a guest i was trying to ask you a
question
earlier which i just couldn't understand
i thought joel
badly misplayed it
and got himself into well for me this is
actually a difficult position if you put
the pawns on
f4 and g3 yeah
that that's an easy draw with f2 g3
these are how you lose it you
okay imagine
that you get king f6
e5
and how do i get in an f4 check
first of all king f6 e5 in itself is
going to be difficult to be made true
what once you get the king on f6 i keep
my rook on the sixth rank another okay
five oh it's easy to get my my king on
f6 and my pawn on e5 i just start with
rook d6 king f6 e5 you can't stop it
okay so
what do you play right now king f6 no i
rook d6 or okay king of six fine you
can't stop me from playing
uh my setup now i go rook a6 and i go
king e5
and then you go rook d6
and now i go
rook a8 crickets
you go rook a sure
and i go
d6 rook f8
and then i go
rook d6
now i go rook e8
and then i give you a hackasito
and i go kingitu
and king
and this is where i'm saying i'm going
to get my pawn to e5
and
if i ever get
my pawn to f4 you start to think
oh oh now i have only moves to save the
game but it's not going to be only moves
that's the thing you think so i i'm
i'm getting nervous for joel i bet i bet
you
i bet you all the guys
who have five points right here right
now
are getting nervous for joel you have to
believe in joel
you have to believe in joel okay okay
this is it this is gonna
and uh dorset what are the times for the
players
i know that's five and a half well uh
occupant has almost seven
well they're not playing on increments
so
and how many moves have they played
actually so uh there are moves
74. 74. yeah dang
i mean we've
we we've seen what two
games that are century-long games at
this event i know mishra had like 120
move game
what's your prognosis for a hundred
moves
yes yes absolutely and uncertainty in
fact not certainty but i think we're
going to get it a hundred moves oh boy
75 only 25 moves to go
that's easy it takes a long time to uh
take to swindle this because i mean he's
going to try we know that
rook to b3 is coming right
or maybe you can go rook to a3
so one moment ago you put your rook on
e8 and defended from
what you might say from behind right
right right this other way that joel is
playing is he's defending it from the
side
uh both options are good in your opinion
um yes absolutely rook to a3 makes a lot
of sense okay
again this end game is draw with with
closed eyes
with closed eyes wow you're so
sure about it okay if if you wow
joel is a grandmaster right i don't
think he has this one i have i've seen
accidents before but this would surprise
me i have to say uh famously i think it
was sergey kerry karjakin lost
rook and four pawns versus rook and four
pawns against magnus carlson
losing rook and three versus rook and
two
is much easier than that
i mean or much harder i got it wrong
i like it
let's say i just says white i just put
the king what's up play passive king on
e2 rook on a2 just go real k2 b2 two
just keep it there what's gonna what's
black gonna do no black is going to go
king e4
actually that might be the easiest way
just because whenever you go e5 and then
f4 i take and then i go f3 mm-hmm okay
so so you hit me
yes that's a good plan so what's a good
plan
let's do what dorsal is recommending
rook on a2 i'm just saying okay so i'll
play rook c5 yoga rook a2 put the king
on it i'll go check you'll put the king
on e2 i'll go king d5
that's fine i'll give you a cherry
no
no i'm just going to do it for the
viewers once again so rook c5 so dorsa
is saying
play passive
well king to d5 play passive
play passive
and let
me get everything i want dorsa so you
gave me
the world essentially okay and
if we're gonna if you're gonna give me
the world give me the entirety of the
world and i get here now how how how are
you defending this you're you're passing
some more what are you doing
are you playing rook a2 now
i don't know well by the way hold on
sorry you can't start you can't that's
the problem so you have to take it in
fact okay
take okay
now immediately up comes my um so let's
go okay
uh what do you call it my um
can't think of it table based it says
drawn
it says draw
uh nothing uh else
and the
and i'm assuming it if i'm gonna win it
i'm gonna win it with f3 right you have
to go f3 okay and then i go king d2
let's say right and again if i'm gonna
win it i assume
i'm gonna but now you have to be careful
okay i go okay four can i go into that
end game i hope not i think i can can
you really then that would be terrible
if you could go into this ending than i
really without you have to be careful
not to lose this one exactly i botched
it
and king g3 and you can go into this
ending okay
so right here after rook a2 and that's
the problem you have to keep the rook on
the fourth rank to uh not allow this
check and then go with the king on e4
and then go f3 if you can but i'm not
going to allow you to go f3 so put the
rook on b4
right now yes okay
and then i move rook c2 let's say okay
and then you go king e4 okay and now i
go f3 this was what uh dorsal was
suggesting this is the this is the key
yes right f3 you take on f3 king goes in
front of the pawn and that's actually an
easy easy draw so if i give you a check
right it's just to
kind of
let's go king d3 king d3
and i
go down
or okay too
also the recon situ is like the worst
place because i know well yeah i asked
for the world you gave me everything i
could possibly want where is the square
for death exactly exactly and i i did it
purposefully and deliberately to improve
my chances so i want to go
kind of sneaking around
uh to the king side now
by the way he went the aggressive way
which was the rook from behind the jaw i
was just going to make a joke that if
the king went to f4 pawn e5
mate yeah yes the i'm thinking what are
the cheapers in this position
oh that's a cheaper uh still
draw
but according to my table base
one two three four moves draws but
there's a lot more losing moves than
those four there's only four and that's
what i'm saying you're you're getting
closer and closer to the point where you
have two moves to draw yeah three moves
to draw and i think
that joel had this so much easier he
really put pressure on himself let me
refresh my board again i apologize
what's the same what the clock times a
copian has five minutes job and jimin is
five and
five twenty four
five 5 24. still plenty of time we
shouldn't be expecting any major
uh mistakes here
you're all looking at a score sheet like
hey
there hasn't been any three move
repetitions no no no no the final take
was about 20 moves ago but it's not even
about takes
it's about uh pawn moves exactly so
whenever i go e5 that resets the class
pretty much right
resets the 50 move counter yeah yes okay
why didn't he play e5 is he just trying
to gain time
like again if he just i don't think he
should be trying to gain time because i
think what he should be trying to do is
put pressure on joel's time exactly
that's his only chance right now right
if he does make random moves and allows
joel to build up some more time then i
think that's detrimental to his chances
exactly joe
every time i think joel is going to go
for the
uh aggressive defense the the the
defense from behind he comes back with
the defense from the side he's just
played the move rook a5
rook a5 right no rook yes he did
no i've got to refresh my board
apologies
here we go rook
a5 so against the problem e5 right yes
but then then what then well e5 f4
that's okay and then i take i take so
once you get
to f4 we exchange that and then i go
from behind
e5 f4 takes takes and then you go all
the way back down right oh setting up
shop for pawn to e5
you was worried about a check from the
side that's surprising
can i just hide my king on g2 on call
it's good
as white
no no sorry not in this position in the
game
right in the game i actually don't think
the king is better placed on g2 if i
remember correctly it's
it's it's easier with the king on itu
let's just put it that way
fair
because
with the king on g2
you will be able to get pinned on the
second rank
and then you have to worry about f4 and
if we exchange those pawns g3 coming
and you you don't want to deal with that
keep the king on it
okay we do have a
reset of our 50 move counter he did play
e6 e5
and for those of you who are predicting
a hundred moves
i'm almost there
we're looking you predicted right
over 81 yeah right
[Music]
well both of these players have a lot of
experience but what they don't have
is a lot of energy
at this moment they're running on
fumes
i spoke i spoke with larry yesterday he
said that the club
has a very nice room where they cater
and have a lot of snacks
and
for larry i'll be right back yeah i'll
be right back as well right
uh that that uh he needs those snacks to
uh keep his energy levels up sorry
dorset you were about to ask
about this position
um oh yes can i just go back here okay
five
yes that's what he's waiting
for
yep he's waiting for black to make a
a stake with f4 so let's say you go rook
a5
and let's say i go
rook check
where would you like to go
ah
e3 not d3 why not d3
no let's go e3 oh no we were talking d3
sorry
b
be brave
not d3 not today so we were no dorsa is
expecting rook a5 and i was asking her
would she put her king on g2
in case of a check yeah that's cool
because i was
more or less asking about this if you
were no doors no more number take f3
stuff you're giving the uh the fox some
chances unnecessary chances exactly he's
trying to out fox you don't allow him to
do that no cocaine who's the fox here
he tried to trick you oh i thought it
was joe benjamin oh yasser is the father
is the [ __ ] i am not a fox you're the
fox i'm a wolf
and i'm hungry for pawns i was trying to
grab uh these no this is actually where
it gets a bit tricky after f4 right with
the king on f1 that's what i'm saying
don't go too i'll i accept let's just go
king to e3 okay so if you go rook a5 and
i go
f4
okay
and my next move is check you're gonna
go
that's the first rank now you take and
you go behind
you take
i go behind
the way
and i go check
that's right have i played king since
what the previous move instead of
working eight could i just cook in d3
and now i go kinky one
uh
again you're kind of this is where you
start to get a little bit
careful your king is
cut away from the cakes maybe it's still
okay yeah i don't know
but uh this is where i start saying uh
people are getting nervous back at the
hotel looking at how joel would be
playing this sorry christian you were
saying that you were going to go
where here
in this moment
after rook c2 check all right let's try
to be the most precise let's go king f1
sure king f going to pretend to give you
some chances
wow
can i play a cheapo upon f3 exactly that
was the that was the first thing that
came to my mind as well kings you want
and now you sidestep the cheapo yes
oh and i can't get even though i feel
like i'm i'm doing some bad things right
now so right i don't think i should do
this but let's keep going let's keep
going well i i'm thinking that uh f4 is
on the board guys by the way that then
that's our our 50 move counter thing
again
we're never going to get to 50 moves
just when you think you're about to make
it then your opponent makes a a pawn
move and and again we we've witnessed
four decisive games out of the five in
the senior section it's like the seniors
became the juniors and they started
swinging
and four in the ladies as well uh it's
it's it's
it's crazy um
sorry we do have f4 on the board i want
to just refresh my board
well one thing that joel should do
right now is to take on f4 which she did
yes he did yes because if not then that
will just be painful well then you have
really in this position then you really
start to get scared like if you play
king you're scared yeah i mean
no
you're uh
you're you could you could be winding up
for some kind of a checkmating net so he
took
yes
and now we see a rook on a5
okay waiting
if i were in vladimir shoes i would
ask you to declare
declare rook check are you going to
defend on g2 or are you going to defend
on e2 i feel fine about you too
[Music]
okay
as we've got some time as this game
continues let's just review our current
standings after eight rounds with the
girls dorsa do the honors sophie morris
suzuki clear first
seven and seven out of eight
and she has secured a playoff at least
at least point italia cervantes who is
tied for second with jenna for you at
six points
so that's gonna be a rough one either
either game for all the marvels yeah
either they're gonna to be honest
natalia wins i think that's gonna be a
three-way playoff because jennifer you
is playing the the um
the bottom um
yeah
annie marie villa versus jennifer
jennifer is like
wow she will be looking at that as for
victory and in the junior standings is
it as close
uh kind of yeah i mean christopher eus
is still having a clear lead with an
extra point
which does guarantee him at least
playoffs as well and the only one who
could theoretically catch him is andrew
hong who andrew does andrew play
christopher in the last round would be
another one
um andrew and christopher they're both
so the number one and two in the in this
round are playing the bottom two
so christopher will play against carissa
yep
with the black pieces
and then andrew will play against pedro
and here are the pairings for the junior
beautiful thank you thank you and
yeah a lot of it's going to be a lot of
fights
anyone christopher uh pardon me carissa
yep versus the christopher you gabe i
mean
everybody will be looking at that one as
pedro espinosa with the white pieces up
against andrew hung and we have seen
some incredible preparation from andrew
i'm expecting him to bring it tomorrow
and he's just saying karissa if there's
ever time for you to play uh
the tournament game of the tournament
please do it tomorrow
and uh how about the girl's parents well
uh talia is playing sophie and that's
gonna be one oh yes
and uh jennifer you is paired with
um valeo who's not really having a good
tournament
and
yeah anyone else here no i mean
up against uh with five and a half
points she's out of first that's clear
but she really wants a podium finish
meaning in the top three
as well uh the g the seniors is actually
going to be an amazing uh finish
we do expect joel to hang on and make a
draw in this game
but we're gonna have a great battle in
the senior and the likelihood of a
playoff in that section is enormously oh
yes
definitely
and joel has
played king to g2
two loneliest players three
three we got our actually i think we
actually have more arbiters than players
because uh we have uh
three arbiters oh i see the snacks
yeah
we missed out what have we been missing
whatever it is those guys are having
you know send it over exactly
for for inspection
rook check so i think he found the right
and the easiest configuration because
right now i'm just simply going to keep
contact with your pawns as well as the
king i'm going to attack if you try to
escape the ie4 the g-pawn right and then
you will have to return
i don't think there's any way in which
you can make f6
maybe yeah
keeping the king the black king tethered
to the g pawn whenever you go off the f
file i'll give you a check and then go
back to g8 i think that's the easy very
easy route out
i agree
wholeheartedly with that uh if you would
have the rook on the second rank maybe
you would stand for transparency i would
think i'm thinking if the
white king were for example on the d3
square
with the rook
cutting off the king from going to
uh the king side maybe i'd have some
chances and now this one rook f8 yes and
that is a really uh
tickling pawn
if you're going to play pawn f3 exactly
pawn f3 always king g3 yes
no he he he played it brilliantly
the defense was was there was on point
joe benjamin has been doing a lot of
grand master in residence stuff for the
club so if any of you are interested
there will be
lots of videos about
him doing lectures on our youtube
channel joel has written a number of
books i really like his articles he's a
i i think his
clarity of writing
is
wonderful i really enjoy his books i
enjoy his articles
and i remember doing
uh back in the day a commentary with him
for
the icc the internet chess club
and somehow the two of us
we'd end up and it was so much fun we'd
sacrifice everybody's pieces
except our own of course i mean that's
what commentators do
we thought your game exactly and he
that's where i picked up throwing the
patties
from joel he was like
i want to throw some paddies you know
and
that was what he meant by the sacrifices
and uh well vladimir is
he's still trying look he tried against
shabbat and he got rewarded he did
he's trying against joel he has
absolutely nothing to lose exactly and i
have to say the seniors have been
proving to be extremely competitive
players all of them every single round
they're bringing it i know
it is remarkable uh this
uh pass move if you will
um it asks white a question do you want
to move your king and if the answer is
yeah i'll play king g1 what's the
problem
then f3 and your king doesn't get to g3
oh joel knows it
and he played nice
from the other side
yes exactly he went rook a8
uh
so
essentially what joel wants to do is any
f3 check he wants to meet with king g3
he doesn't want to get checkmated by uh
rook landing on h3 but f3 check and then
he could play rook a5 and that is super
super easy so what i was saying just a
moment ago this this cagey little move
king rook g7 by vladimir saying to his
opponent okay you go ahead and make your
move joel as we know made the move rook
a8 but if he had moved his king then
vladimir would have said okay
now i can go f3 and your king can't go
to g3 and i'll keep playing is that a
draw invitation
that could be a repetition
i'm counting okay
well that would mean that we don't make
it to 100
we don't make it to 100.
g7 and that's uh a draw offer
we're gonna move 92 everybody oh no i'm
going to lose the bat exactly come on
vladimir eight more moves you can do it
i challenge him to find all of the good
what was this [ __ ]
what are the odds that this game will go
to 100 moves
and what are we playing for
um well it determined if i win we're
playing for a lot
nice if i lose it was an ego voice
beautiful
i'll let you know in just a few moments
in a few minutes
thank you kristen
all right so let's keep checking
let's keep giving those pesky tracks
that's right
and by the way after a rook to f8 if you
go to e4
i can even go
f3 i just want to check
let's just keep it but probably just
keep checking
that's the same you want to go f3
yeah that's that's still a draw uh-huh
that is still an easy draw actually i
believe
i'll take the pawn and i'll believe you
later later yes
you'll make me prove it right
well at this position i'm quite certain
we've reached we've seen it again and
we've seen joel play rook g8 in this
position
yeah this one after g8
i think if rook to g6 will be played we
might see a three four repetition there
and by the way again the clocks has not
become a factor in this game i'm looking
through the game and i don't think that
king on f5 and robot f6 has been played
before this is the first one wow okay
because the king was on g5 for a while
and then there was a palm tree then
everything must have been from my
analysis feel free to correct me no no
no no i mean
it must have been from my analysis that
i had king on f5 and rook on f6 and we
can see actually joe making some notes
on his uh score sheets i think that's
exactly what he's looking for he's just
noting where he sees the repetition
and he says like yes this is the first
time this is second time and then our
third
try he's going to
politely offer a draw if he refuses call
the arbiter and make a draw
uh we were talking about that
i think it was during
the opening ceremonies with my uh senior
colleagues
how
people have offered them draws but kind
of it was
so sammy rushevsky had this way of
offering a draw which was
are you playing for a win
yeah are you playing for a win
and you would go
uh
uh let me think about it and then you go
okay i'll accept the draw and he said no
no no no no i didn't offer you a draw i
asked if you were playing for a win
it was like what yeah
that was a cheapo right so did anybody
offer you a draw in a way that kind of
threw you backwards like are they
offering me a draw
yes or no but but let me just tell you
that the the
weird one that i've had that's what i
was
searching for
me it happened to one of my one of my
friends was telling me that's something
that
they used to do and it worked
so when they would get low on time
everybody's long time and
um this individual would um like you had
two seconds on your clock i would i
would not stop the clock i would you
know reach hand and you would shake
hands and then the opponent would think
oh great it's a draw or no no my
opponent is resigning
right or like offering a draw or
whatever and by the time you're thinking
boom your clock goes to zero right and
they would say yeah we've used this
technique so many times i was like oh
that
i don't know if that's illegal but
that's very unethical right if it
happened to me i would fight it that was
called the army service
my opponent
was disturbing me
yeah but their cameras here so that's
right
any any peculiar draw offers in your
career that you've come up against
no no i cannot think of any but what i
can think is when i offered uh well
actually they did offer me a draw and
then they rescinded the offer oh yes
i was thinking whether to accept or not
and then they came back to the board and
they were like no no i forget about it i
forget about my draw but you can't take
the draw
away exactly and i said that you cannot
do that we shook hands he started crying
because he was winning and that was it
we went on with our lives that was when
we were like 10 years of age i see i see
but once you got into the master ranks
and stuff like that i cannot think of
any
peculiar okay here's the convention
right
you and i are playing dorsa
and it's a tough game whatever i for
whatever reasons i offer you a draw
which has been the case
oh my gosh dinner's on christian
everybody
everybody in the central west and
christian is inviting us all out to
dinner run run i'm sorry for you
christian that's just a bad break there
buddy
and uh dorset did the honors uh here i'm
way tied
those are fights that's a five-way tie
of fives
exactly
it's it's kind of deceptive but uh
and
the parents for tomorrow are going to be
very exciting for us
okay let's start with the fives so we
have four fives playing each other so
shabala five playing dukely five right
uh sorry garbage five playing
christensen five and there is one five
pointer letterberry
he's playing nick deferming who's not
having a good tournament he might be
thinking
you guys make a draw on tables three and
four i'll take first places
exactly and i'll take the 20 000
cash
for my retirement fund
final thoughts christian long day long
day but what around once again and the
script is made in hollywood of course we
have three amazing uh tournaments and
all of them are still up for grabs even
the junior section christopher you does
seem like he's running away with the
event but still andrew hung one point
behind and christopher will have to
defend the black side against carissa ib
so definitely i'm having my eyes on that
one in the senior section these guys are
just simply bringing it to the table and
i'm very excited to see what's going uh
to happen tomorrow in all three sections
we're going to have an amazing day guys
championship saturday coming up don't
miss it we'll see you all tomorrow good
night everybody bye
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the st louis
chess club is prohibited
you